anh alo alo
Ừ cái đôi trẻ nhỏ Alo các bạn nghe gì
không
à Hôm nay chắc là sớm hơn một tí mình đã
ngồi từ 7 giờ đợi đến giờ rồi nhưng mà
chắc À hôm trước thì nợ các bạn hơi
nhiều thứ hôm nay sẽ chia sẻ nhiều cái
có nhiều cái trước nó
từ trước gì vậy
Ừ chắc nhớ bắt một vài gái thì phải
A5
em
nhớ không lầm mà hôm trước là mình à
ở cuối buổi thì mình đi lấy cái ghế vậy
à Hôm nay có tí hồi hộp hơn Kiều
nhớ các bạn
việc thứ bảy vừa rồi không Không dậy cảm
thấy kéo chồng bằng cái gì đấy có mấy
bạn thì cũng inbox hỏi là
hỏi hỏi hàm các thứ
nhưng mà thực ra gì à
Để trung hòa chuyện đấy chuyện bên lề tí
với các bạn thì mình
vệ đến bây giờ thì vẫn ổn chứ
ở cấp để ảnh hưởng các bạn nó
Ừ
thôi đi dạy mình đương như là mình cũng
kiểu thế tôi khuya có những ngày được
không về ngày nào cũng là lạc quan tới
sáng được nhưng mà hạn chế để ảnh hưởng
đến sinh viên nếu có thể
Ừ mình cũng mới mò lại cái á
ở mỏ để chỉnh cái ups để mà livestream
này cho nó tốt cho các bạn thấy hôm nay
mượt hơn Ngon hơn đúng không
ăn dặm Buồn à
không Mình bây giờ nhớ buồn thì mình chỉ
muốn ngủ thôi
bộ phim
Ừ
mấy hôm nay còn mang một đánh Cún về
thành ra kiểu mình hướng ngoại mà nói là
em
người hướng ngoại thì ra rất thích nuôi
nuôi chó vì kịp
hi vọng sẽ hướng ngoại và nó sẽ cậu làm
tâm trạng ổn hơn ý
Ừ thôi để mình không nói chuyện hẳn là
bên lề về sau anh thế nữa Ờ Ờ
mình à
À hôm nay mình tranh thủ livestream sớm
thì mình sẽ có cái này
kể về một người em
Hot girl là khi có nhiều thời gian hơn
như thế này tận nửa tiếng nữa chắc là
mình sẽ tranh thủ chém gió nó dài hơn
một tí đó mình sẽ
kể về một người bạn của mình trước đi
một người bạn
từ
hồi cấp 2 khiến cho mình à
bí quyết tâm trở thành một người thích
làm
ở kiệu có tấm ảnh hưởng thích làm thay
đổi
Ừ quan điểm góc nhìn người khác
ở
đầu tiên là phải kể đến là hồi cấp 1 của
mình ngày 29 ra từ trường mẫu giáo cái
gì Vân vân Ý mình là cậu
vì sao màu sắc kết hợp với
nghiện game các thứ Ừ hai cái đây nó
khiến cho mình khó kết bạn
sinh nhật của mình là gần như là mẹ toàn
rủ anh em họ hoặc là hàng xóm hồn khối
lỗ với lộ bọn trẻ con hàng xóm để nó qua
sinh nhật mình vì việc các bạn mình rơi
ít bạn hạn chế là cấp 1 của mình chỉ 122
người bạn thôi
chúng mình vẫn cố chơi với tất cả các
bạn bè mình được sự thì mình có nói
chung là cái tính mình không phù hợp với
tất cả bạn đấy có thể chế các thành viên
cấp 2 cũng vẫn vậy
bộ phim nhưng mà Chính vì thế mình rất
nguồn cái bạn ấy
chị đã lên cấp 2 mình
Vì mình thấy một ông cũng kiểu hướng nội
mình cố gắng chuyện bạn ấy buổi đầu có
chuyện bạn ấy đấm thằng mặt mình rồi vợ
là cút đi cứ
Ừ nhưng mà kiểu Chắc là máu à
u máu mở
Việt kiều mình
anh vẫn cố đấm ăn xôi vẫn chỉ cối để mà
kết bạn với bạn đấy
thì à Bạn ấy chứ không chơi với ai trong
lớp cả bà vì sau mình nói chuyện bạn đấy
thì bạn ơi cấp 2 bạn đấy
Em chả hiểu sao bạn để có tư tưởng trở
thành sát thủ vẫn chưa
Ừ ông ấy có bố làm công an cũng trước Hà
to mẹ thì cũng làm cán bộ nhà nước Kiều
cả gia đình khiến cho bạn ấy kiểu bị
giam cầm
a cho bia ở Trung à
sống như kiểu là Rập khuôn mẫu ấy cả Thế
bạn này không được đi chơi
đi học là phải về nhà gấp đôi số thứ con
trai con trai trắng ở con gái phía bạn
đấy cần kia rồi ra được
ờ ờ
anh ở đấy bạn hãy xem anh mẹ nhiều vào
đây đây để tôi kể cho ông đó là bạn ơi
Không chưa ra đọc truyện tranh không có
chuyện không có kênh gì để chơi
chính mình kiểu là người + tiêm nhiễm mà
bạn đầy những khói hư tật xấu của đời
người Huế
Đúng Đúng kiểu vì kéo mình lấy mình à
hướng dẫn Lại chơi game
máy tính bạn ơi sao rộng cũng có ông nội
tối cổ nhưng mà máy tính không lắp mạng
xe
tải chở thế nên là kiểu chơi các game
offline này xong rồi về sau cũng
cũng chỉ hôm đấy vào con đường đi bu
kiểu Hồi đấy có Blog chuyện ấy chia sẻ
ông đấy thôi đọc truyện đầu tiên trong
đời Đọc truyện tranh nhỏ con sâu đã đục
khoét tâm hồn mày như thế nào ạ
Ê tôi dậy hư con công an cái gì ông ấy
bây giờ bỏ ước mơ làm sát thủ rồi đấy
đấy gọi là chỉ ông ấy vào con đường hiền
lành hơn nhiều ạ ừ ừ
Ừ cái gì à
Ừ nhưng mà đưa ra ngoài suốt quá thích
2D hơn là 3D tức à Thích thế giới đang ở
hơn thế giới thực đó ngày ngày chị ngồi
chơi game một like nữa cả ngồi xem chiến
tranh đi
thế nhưng ông ấy đang từ một thằng kiểu
bất cần đời học hành thế cũng nói chung
là tầm trung của lớp chuyến xếp thứ hai
mấy đứa lợi về sau cũng nhanh đua mình
mình thì từ trước nay mình bảo mình
nghiện mọt sách này ra là mình họ cũng
tương đối giữa ổn trong lớp mình kiểu bị
gắn liền của con số 3 về lúc nào sẽ thứ
luôn sau một thằng con nhà người ta với
lớp chưa lớp trưởng thì lúc nào được
điểm nói gì Ừ nhưng mà cái gì ông này
xếp thứ hai mấy mà về sau còn ganh đua
điểm số với tôi cơm ạ miễn vì mình cảm
thấy mình thay đổi Ông ấy rất rõ rệt
thay đổi gần như bước ngoặt cuộc đời của
anh ấy
là một bước ngoặt rất lớn
ạ sau đó vì sao mày trở nên vui tính
người hoa đồng bạn bè các thứ cũng bởi
vì ngồi đọc truyện tranh kiểu đầu truyện
tranh kiểu thấy các nhân vật chính như
nào nói trước
anh ở đấy sau đó về sau mày tình cảm gì
đúng không ạ sau đó hai sau với tình cảm
thì ông ấy nơi cấp 3 thì ông ấy
ông ấy lại thiếu điểm để mà vào trường
cùng tôi thì em hãy nghe là ông ấy và
trường khác sau đó lên như ông ngồi kết
bạn người khác cũng kiểu dạng là mọi
người thì Tưởng bề ngoài ông ấy vui tính
kiểu người hướng ngoại như dâu hướng nội
vào ngoài kiểu là một view ngầm hiểu sao
tự nhiên về sau lại quen một ghim nhầm
khác là một bạn nữ cái cùng 12 người đi
Bun nhà hay gần nhau nữa Thành A hai
người yêu nhau và
Ừ Kệ đời đúng nghĩa thế kiểu chỉ chơi
game và đi chơi cùng nhau thôi và ngồi
đọc truyện tranh tình cờ thế
Thế mai mấy người vẫn cười ấy rồi có con
cá thứ thứ
Ừ nhưng mà ông ấy về sau mới Bơ luôn tôi
với kiểu chỉ chỉ yêu người yêu Trời ơi
tao tìm được tình yêu của đời mình
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà tôi vẫn khẳng định là từ đấy
khiến nó tôi kiểu
áo kiểu tự tin là mình sẽ thay đổi được
một con người nào đó kiểu
ạ bây giờ vì sau Mày bị gì bây giờ ông
người hơi vua mà đó là lần cuối ông ấy
có nhà nước tôi thì ở người cười đấy nhớ
ông ấy kêu là vinh hạnh của mày mà tao
mời các thứ thế thôi không đi luôn chưa
Thế nhưng mà
anh cũng nha
anh vui mà vui khi mà thay đổi cuộc đời
một con người ở đó
ở nơi nào tôi cảm thấy các cậu có động
lực để mà kéo
em rất rất thích khi mà nhìn thấy khuôn
mặt ai đó không quên cái này mới vậy
Chân Trời Mới Tôi rất thích đi dạy học
như à kìa
Em thử chia sẻ góc nhìn của mình nó các
thứ II anh không với tôi thì đấy không
có chuyện buồn à
Ừ anh để làm nghề gì ạ từ cao tuổi không
rõ nữa nhưng người nhiều người vẫn bị
hình ngựa mày theo người người của bố đi
làm công an thì vậy
mà tôi khẳng định luôn à Tôi có ông anh
nữa
Ừ chắc ông ấy không muốn xem video ở đâu
không anh họ Kiều Bố làm con to Công an
với bé à Hồi tuổi gọi tuổi dậy thì cháu
với kiểu thế
anh cũng đi đua xe cá thứ kiểu bất cần
đời cậu rất ghét công an có thứ mà đến
bây giờ vẫn làm công an à hình như là nó
bị diệt quân đấy đấy không có bố làm
công an thì
Kiều tầm tuổi thì trâu ấy sẽ rất là bốc
đồng sau đó với sau vẫn gương nhìn thấy
chưa ạ
Ừ tao hồi đấy chưa Làm đa cấp đến hồi
đại học thì 13 đầu vào hồi năm nhất Mà
năm nhất chẳng có việc gì làm thể tham
gia đầy đủ mọi công ty
U60 lá tham gia cả cao cấp với mà đứng
như cái này nó không liên quan đến rút
về à
I định hướng cuộc đời của mình nữa đó là
mình kẻo bị vừa rồi mình còn nói qua là
mình kéo cảm thấy rất thiếu thốn về tình
cảm rất kiểu rất cần bạn kia rồi thế và
bao gồm cần cả bạn đời đã cần tìm tri kỷ
các từ ngữ nữa thành ra là mình cũng vào
đa cấp để mà bia
khoa học cách đường người đi lừa gái cho
thuê
Bởi cái này có ghi lại video ấy nói câu
này chết nhưng mà nói trước mà vào đấy
họp xong như là cứ giúp cục thì vẫn
không đi lừa được gái mà toàn để gái lừa
như trước đây tiêu tốn rất nhiều tiền
vào cho gái buồn vãi ạ
em gửi tiền để đóng tiền game về bây giờ
lên áp Vừa Đâu
ừ ừ
anh nói chung là tôi nuôi khá nhiều vợ
của Có khi một anh em mà nói trong đây
đi
à à
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung à
cái đấy tao liên quan đến việc là mình
định hướng một tí là về cái định hướng
của mình đó là mình Tại sao tự nhiên
nhiều người tự hỏi mình tại sao phải đi
tìm bạn khai thật kia vợ sớm thế Cái gì
đó để tụi ăn vì chơi mà hai cái thứ vẫn
Vân thì mình cảm thấy mình định hướng
tương lai mình nhiều người định hướng
tương lai ở giàu nhưng ra giàu để làm gì
Giàu thể
cho tôi một thằng con trai thì ra là
lương 5 triệu cũng đủ sống mươi triệu
thì vẫn ngủ sớm chồng có cuộc sống khá
hơn hai mươi phần trăm triệu về cơ bản
nó vẫn đủ sống nhưng cuộc sống khá hơn
nếu mà mình xác định chị Giàu thì nóng
ra mông lung
số mệnh định hướng gỡ ra là để kia
có gì mà để sau nuôi gia đình chị ạ thì
đương nhiên là mình sẽ phải xác định cái
ý định là kiếm gia đình đã thì mới nuôi
gia đình thì nên là mình chủ động đi
quan điểm nói chung quan điểm Mình rõ
ràng hơn nhiều anh em cùng cùng lắm kiểu
anh em cùng lứa có khi đến tầm tuổi này
vẫn đang bay người yêu thế mình xác định
rõ ràng rồi
Thu Hà nói đùa thì hơi nhưng đương nhiên
à
mình không được Hồi tiếc về cái gì lắm
Ừ mình rất hạn chế để mà về sau mình hứa
nên là mình làm cái gì mình cũng thưa
anh nghĩ xem là 5 năm hay 10 năm nữa
mình sẽ hối hận vì quyết định này không
ở nhà Đôi khi mình cũng kiểu biết được
có thể là gì Ví dụ là hẹn hò giống như
vừa rồi mình nói rằng ạ Cái gì là chưa
chắc là cưới người ta đúng không Nhưng
mình cảm thấy là chúng ta là bị trăm
mình cũng không ân hận là về sau bị hẹn
hò người ta rằng ạ
nhà mình
có như ở trải nghiệm hay gì gì đó nếu mà
không thành công đúng không
thì mình sẽ
em có một chút bài học gì đó gì Nói
chung là kịp trải qua thành nhiều gì nó
càng tạo cho mình đứa con người như bây
giờ chắc thế Mọi người yêu cũ là một
người thầy tốt nhất mà ông đọc có lấy về
chưa Bởi vì
các kiểu nếu mà ông nào mà quen tôi chắc
ở đây ra ít anh em nhưng mà anh em điện
anh Mạnh Tuấn em ạ
à quên mình à bây giờ cũng phải 35 thì
phải tầm đấy 335 thì à
chị sẽ thấy là mình hay đổi rất rất
nhiều từ thời từ đấy Thời đấy đến bây
giờ bởi vì mình trải qua rất nhiều cung
bậc cảm xúc cũng như là rất nhiều trách
nhiệm Kiếm Thế ừ ừ
cho nên là mình kiểu cảm thấy là chẳng
có gì hối tiếc vậy ạ Mình chưa ăn cơm à
Mình cũng đang run run lại Đợi tí mình
đi lấy cái áo ấy
ừ ừ
à à
em mặc áo rồi chúng ta tiếp tục trò
chuyện
Được nghe những ngày đầu như kiểu mặc
váy và rồi đi ngồi cãi
bộ phim
ừ ừ
À
mà hôm nay không mở điều hòa đâu Mình
mới nuôi chó này chắc là sẽ không Không
thì mới điều hòa được
Ừ nhưng mà mình kiểu cho mình còn liên
quan đến có yếu tố cũng có tí Bị bệnh về
cẩn thận nữa
ở nơi nào chuột là thứ ba là mình
số phận là mình không nên nói chuyện chứ
làm đông không nên đều bị ám thảm nhiều
nhưng mà thật ra có rất nhiều đứa tàu
mình cảm thấy à Mình không thể
à Vì nó mà mình
Ừ từ bỏ đam mê hay quyết định của mọi
thứ vào đời mình được không
à À lại là màn làm bạn quá để chúng ta
sẽ quay kể về một người em đúng không
kìa ạ
ở tại sao tự nhiên mình để cặp với người
em ở đây mày gần đây mình có tự
tự nhiên gần đây ông ấy lại mình nhắn
tin lại mình
Ừ thì da mình nó rất nhiều vậy em nên
cầu duy nhất Ông đợi ông em đấy mình đặt
hàng biệt danh là
em em trai ruột
cho dù mình con muộn mẹ nhiều mình từ
trước là mình rất thích có anh em em
ruột về Huế
a baby Bình và mình kiểu thiệt hôn đi
trạm cái này ra càng có nhiều người thân
là tốt đấy
Ừ
nhưng mà nói chung về ông em ruột này
thì như nào thì mình quen chính em đấy
nó trong dư tim công ti này Ờ rồi đấy
mình còn chưa làm kiểm duyệt nhóm nhưng
mình nghĩa kiểu thấy em lấy hoạt động
sôi nổi tự nhiên chảy sang bắt chuyện đi
kiểu gì ấy hay hai đứa nói chuyện nhau
rồi kìa Nói chuyện cảm thấy hợp hợp tự
như em mình hướng nội nhưng mình cảm
thấy mình cũng có tài năng gì đó nói
chuyện được với người hướng nội kiểu thế
chơi cùng mình hướng ngoại mình nói
chuyện nhiều vãi thường họ sẽ ghét những
cái thằng được ngồi nói chuyện ngồi nói
liên tục xung quanh ngọn Ừ
nhưng mà
à à
anh nói chung à la mai một tí rồi rồi em
đấy á nữ sinh 2k hay nhớ
Ừ chị nhớ này mới trẻ hai ca mấy
anh nói chung là ông ấy bây giờ năm nhất
nhất bây giờ 2k hay không
À thế à
ờ ờ
à à
thì tại sao tự nhiên mày nói lỗ tuổi đây
bởi vì lớp 10 12 Lớp 12 mình gặp anh đấy
nghĩ ra em lấy về lập trình
Vì sao nó đi à Dậy rồi đấy cũng là một
trong những học trò đầu tiên mình dạy về
lập trình
xin liên hệ tôi đòi tiền Tôi chỉ nói
chuyện cà phê ạ trước ngày tôi chỉ nói
tiếng cà phê cãi à
Ừ ừ bây giờ em mới lên 52 rồi nhưng mà
em mới bỏ đại học thì phải cái hợp học
đại học cảm thấy chán quá nên mới nghỉ
bạn với ra là em về đã học lập trình
ngay từ năm lớp 11 2 lớp 12 rồi phải qua
em lấy về giùm nói em đi làm có thể đi
làm được rồi nhưng mà ông ấy vẫn thích
trải nghiệm cuộc sống
cho nên ngoài chưa đi làm thôi ba ông ấy
tự học ở nhà rất nhiều cái
Ô kìa
thì tại sao tự nhiên mình để cặp vụ đề
ra đây Vì ạ Mình cảm thấy mình định
hướng em mới dồi cửa mình chỉ kém em đầy
có mỗi hai ba buồn đâu để lập trình nó
ra nhé mình tự học
anh vẫn khẳng định lại những cái ông
sủng hướng nội ông ấy tự học kinh vãi
ông biết tự nghĩ mọi thứ ông ý thức ra
chẳng hỏi han thêm gì mình mấy nữa cứ
cắm đầu học sau Bây giờ Bây giờ gần đây
Mình mới nhắn tin lại cho em đấy không
Dạo này thế nào thì em mới ạ học toàn
những thứ cao sĩ hồi Trung à
anh cũng mình thấy ở được ra cũng ngân
hàng dùng biết học đấy cũng tầm tuổi cho
trẻ bữa giờ giỏi những con nhà người ta
cần thế kiểu họ đam mê ngày đêm cày được
mà kết hợp Họ có tư duy nữa thì họ bắt
tóc nhanh hơn mình rất nhiều đấy
Ừ
nhưng mà đấy nó nó cũng là một tí động
lực cho anh em ở đây đó anh em ở đây
nghe Huế xong cảm thấy vui
vì nó có những người ta thêm không theo
được đúng không
Ừ nhưng mà lại nhắc về vụ
Không chỉ về mỗi con nhà người ta đấy
gần đây là chính sinh viên các bạn ạ Các
bạn cũng nhắn tin cho mình
Ừ từ những buổi đầu học luôn đó là
anh em không theo ngày này
anh em sinh viên năm nhất năm hai thuận
chưa đi làm rồi Thế mình có khi mình
không gọi lại em được Phải gọi là bạn
hỏi chị anh được
ăn canh chị ấy có nhắn tin cho mình rồi
hỏi lại hôm nay buổi đầu tiên mình học
anh cảm thấy á cũng dễ hiểu để mình thử
thì theo xem thế nào
A và từ các từ hôm nào đến bây giờ mấy
người vẫn còn nhắn tin với mình
Ê bà bỏ là
đi học thì bây giờ vẫn học được
dẫn làm bài tập về đủ các thứ tình cảm
thấy à kiểu nhẫn bạn lấy tạo mình một
cái động lực rất là to lớn
xe cứu hỏa đương nhiên là có những người
kiểu dân đang ngủ Lúc đầu như thế rồi Về
sau họ
à vì rất nhiều yếu tố mà họ cần họ không
theo nữa
Ừ mình biết tỷ lệ vận 28 hết sẽ thấp hơn
Ừ nhưng mà
à mình mình
Anh Vẫn Luôn có niềm tin không trọng thế
giống như chuyện tình cảm của mình vừa
rồi cảnh ạ Nếu luôn niềm tin và sẽ thay
đổi được
Ở đời ai đó không hẳn mình đã nói là
mình dậy như thế này không hàn là để các
bạn tất cả đều theo ngày này bởi vì A
theo ngày này có rất nhiều yếu tố nữa
thậm chí là các bạn còn bị tự ti theo
kéo có mấy thằng con nhà người ta nói
theo ngành này chọn cho mình theo kịp
được làm sao lương mình cao được bằng
bọn nó chẳng hạn thế mình với Vân đúng
không Bởi vì các bạn có thể có những tài
nặng lẻ những cái tài ở mảng khác
Ừ nhưng mà Cái quan trọng là cái việc
mình dậy như này thì rất là dậy công
nghệ thông tin và Thời đại này không ngờ
thừa không thửa mình đang dậy rồi các
bạn tất cả những cái cơ bản nên hoàn
toàn các bạn có thể áp dụng và tư duy
này giống như là tí tôi dậy được công kỹ
năng trâu em ạ Cái cao mới thấy từ trước
này không trao dù nó cứ thế nào ấy cái
kiểu thế nhưng nhiều bạn import ở trong
như tín công ty Hoa cả tăng bài hỏi dùm
đi tìm con gì nó chao Woa 1 phát ra ngay
thật chưa copy cái câu hỏi của ông trao
gỗ cũng ra thế mà ông vẫn luôn nói về
rồi đó là anh
em thử mọi cách trên Google rồi nhưng
không được Tại sao ạ
các kiểu ghế làm Tôi không biết trả lời
cái câu này như thế nào ạ
xe tải Nói chung à
Ừ cái dại có nghĩa tin này mình cảm thấy
không thưa Nên là các bạn
I rap cho này thì mình bảo học xong
chuyên sâu
để mà áp dụng cho các bạn đi làm thì các
bạn lắm
ở mấy cái link cân nhắc việc Có nên học
tiếp hay nên dừng lại đúng không Còn bây
giờ thì mình đã gặp được chữ cơ bản gì
từ từ thôi đúng không bị mất gì đâu mất
1 tiếng buổi tối
thứ ba ba ba buổi một tuần nhưng mất 3
tiếng tâm tâm đấy nếu mà ông không thích
nghe chém gió ngày chị thời lượng học
chị ạ dưới nước một tiếng mà đúng không
ạ
anh không các bạn nên họ nhiều đứa như
là các bạn để dễ kỹ năng chào Google
mình sẽ Không những vậy các bạn về cái
kỹ năng cho Google mà dậy kỹ năng các
bạn về cách hỏi luôn chưa mình thì da
mình Tuấn nói cái bài toán này cho sinh
viên mình rất nhiều rồi kỹ năng hỏi lại
nếu như họ Google mà hỏi mà đúng không
Thì à mình đã từng có cái câu này Mình
đang lên đó là Ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
nếu bạn không
em đặt tên là câu hỏi
thì người
em trả lời gì vậy cũng không có tâm
khi nghe câu này thấy hợp lý không
khi nghe những hợp lý đúng không Tức là
sao cài đặt Tâm ở câu hỏi Tức là sao
nghĩa là các bạn không nên hỏi một cách
vu vơ không nên kia
em không thể cứ nghĩ gì hỏi này chưa
và đương nhiên mình cũng sẽ hỏi nhưng mà
thực sự có thể hiểu mình có câu này nữa
đó là người thông minh cũng hỏi
người không thông minh
cũng hỏi
nhưng chắc chắn là hai người này hỏi
khác nhau
cứ viết các bạn rồi nghĩ kỹ lại thì cái
này cũng thấy bí mà nó mà
cho hợp lý ở chỗ gì Cái này mình đang
hơi bị dạy đờn Tí nhỏ mình về có bà thì
mình là thầy mà đúng không Mình tự đi
Thành thầy đi Dậy ra rồi nơi ạ Mình mình
phải dạy lại các bạn đôi khi là mấy cái
mấy cái này một tí thông cảm à
em có vay bạn thì có thể bỏ qua như ngày
Nhỏ đây góc nhìn của mình nhé
Thì à
ờ ờ
cái kích cách người thông minh đặt câu
hỏi
kìa họ sẽ thường hay suy nghĩ kỹ trước
khi đặt câu hỏi để suy nghĩ kỹ ở đây đó
là gì khi họ tìm kiếm trước khi mà họ họ
để hỏi sao cho nó chuột kiểu thế
từ điển hình là đã từng có người
em chụp cho mình cái trang YouTube một
cái video đang đánh đàn gì vậy
em chụp mỗi cái màn hình rồi đấy Cho hỏi
một câu vu vơ Anh ơi làm thế này nhịn
làm cái này như thế nào ạ
khi bạn đang ngồi xem video một người
đánh đàn ở trên kênh YouTube rồi Bạn ấy
chụp cả cái trang web về cho mình mình
chẳng biết được cái cái này của bạn đấy
là cái gì cả em lấy kiểu gì thế
Ừ cái này là trang web YouTube hay là
đánh đàn hay cái gì đó mình không Mình
chẳng bi anh ấy nghĩa là
đấy chỉ là một ví dụ điển hình trong rất
nhiều ví dụ bây giờ mà tôi mà mở à Chứ
tin committee rồi bấm vào bài đang chờ
duyệt đấy sẽ bấm mà phần câu hỏi các bạn
thấy hàm lượng câu hỏi
em rất rất nhiều
số lượng bài bàng trầu duyệt lại câu hỏi
phải đến 50 phần trăm thì 65 và trong ít
số đó mới là hỏi có tâm thật sự có nhiều
không Hỏi Google Cực anh không biết trả
lời như thế nào luôn nó không biết nên
giờ này không
không duyệt thì cậu không tốt nhưng mà
rửa xong nghỉ có khi chẳng ai trả lời
được như thế
cho nên bây giờ mình sẽ quay lại về cách
kỹ năng hỏi cũng như kỹ năng chào Google
hoa Các bạn nên à
ít nhất là
bình yên à Tra
Google
trước khi họ đúng không
kịch nhất là như thế thứ hai là
Anh điên à Cái này thì các bạn sẽ phải
theo từ khóa
cho nên là tiếng Anh đúng không
Nếu mà không biết rồi tiếng Anh thì các
bạn dùng Google dịch chúng ta nó đỡ đỡ
một phần mà bé em nghe nói thằng ở Minh
Mạng có béo
alo alo
Ừ nếu mà
em nghe nói tao hết cỡ mà các bạn thì bé
ừ ừ
à à
ờ ờ
[âm nhạc]
xe
tải đầu tiên bằng tiếng Anh này Thứ hai
là gì
ờ ờ
để hạn chế nhiều từ
dụ ví dụ điển hình nha ví dụ này ra Làm
thế nào để lấy ngày tháng hiện tại
thì nó sẽ how to get current
datetime này nếu các bạn biết từ khóa
trên nhàng rồi sẽ đến than
ạ sau đó Ý kết hợp với ngôn ngữ lập
trình này à
sử dụng thật sự Dạ em khỏe chẳng hạn
hoặc là fpp gì gì đấy Sau đó các bạn rút
ngắn những cái từ đi hết sức có thể thấy
dù là bỏ tự học tu rồi Ghét nhé để nó sẽ
chia quên đấy time như thế này anh quen
ra ngay đó phía sau về cách tra Google
chưa
Ừ đấy Nó sẽ chỉ nằm nhắn như thế thôi I
À à Với bên công nghệ thông tin này thì
đôi khi các bạn
Xin chào Google không cần phải hiểu nó
lắm Bởi vì các bạn ạ
copy code mà chạy mà hiểu từ từ sau cũng
được không sao
ừ ừ
các bạn cần nhất Thứ Hai là nếu các bạn
cho gồm mà không được thì sao các bạn
vẫn muốn hỏi đúng không Tuy nhiên rồi
các bạn không nên bước mục mà không
thành công thì thì dừng luôn lại đấy Cái
Chết thứ hai thì các bạn sẽ phải ghi
ở mô tả chi tiết
mô tả hạn nó bao gồm đây là gì đó là
cho ví dụ Giả sử đá có bạn từng hỏi mình
là cách để mà lập trình ra một cái nón
nhảy nhảy cửa sổ lên để mà hiển thị ra
bình luận em ạ đái thì
Ừ thì phải mô tả nó như thế
ô chữ hạn chế nói là em muốn làm một cái
la là giống thằng abc.xyz
em chẳng hiểu cái thằng nào thế giới y z
hành hạ
ở đây thì các bạn phải ghi mô tả
Muốn hiển thị nào
hoặc muốn
nó
lúc đầu
anh là gì sau đó là gì ạ
anh hoặc nhập vào là gì In ra là gì em ạ
Đấy
thì các bạn là
Em thử nghĩ lại xem thực sự mình đã từng
hỏi mấy cái kiểu nhà rồi xa chưa đúng
không Thế là các bạn đã ba đồ từ trước
này có thể hỏi sai đấy đúng không bác
Cái thứ ba đó là gì
em không bao giờ nên nói cái câu đó là
em tra Google Em thử mọi cách mà vẫn
không được Bởi vì chuyện Thứ nhất là
chưa chắc các bạn đã thử đúng
áo kiểu thế
Ừ thứ hai là nhớ bạn nói với mình giống
như đã từng có ông Đăng bài lên em em
cần sửa cái máy tính em mới chơi Z và em
đã thử mọi cách trên Google mà nó vẫn
không được nếu mà bạn thường mọi cách
trên Google mà nó không được thì các bạn
nên đập mày mua máy mới là thằng như thế
Tôi phía
thử mọi cách không chạy thì đúng là đập
máy nữa anh cứu mỗi ngày đúng không
em cũng chỉ có thể là gì Một là ông chứ
thử hết cách hay là ông
Em thử xài rồi thì biết lạ ông không vừa
nên nó đấy mà nên nói cái gì đó là ba
này nó lạ tùy
Ừ nếu thử rồi thì đề cập
là đã thực
như thế nào Cách gì để cập cái này ngủ
chưa
ừ ừ
Ừ
cái đấy là kinh nghiệm hỏi của mình
Anh hỏi này là đang áp dụng cho công
nghệ thông tin nhưng được Té là mình
nghĩ lại
ở trên bất cứ môi trường nào các bạn đi
làm người ta không không có nghĩa vụ
phải trả lời các ạ nên các loại cũng nên
hỏi đúng không chưa trả lời nên họ Ừ
nhưng mà các bạn nên hỏi ít nhất là theo
ba ba cái này ba tiêu chí này đúng không
các bạn hỏi nên chọn hơn một tí hạn chế
kiểu
em hỏi không có tâm hỏi không có tâm thì
sẽ không nhận được câu trả lời không tâm
hòa không trả lời
Ừ nhưng mà mình thì mình từng đi dậy rồi
mình quên giỗ sinh viên rồi nghe các bạn
hỏi kiểu gì mình cũng sẽ có trả lời các
bạn cũng như là cố Cố hỏi lại các bạn
xem
chị
xem câu hỏi thực sự là gì
Ừ nhưng mà các bạn là hỏi người khác thì
không phải ai cũng dễ tính như mình là
sự nhé Có nhiều bạn nhắn tin mình nói
thấy mình không chảnh lắm Mình mình tự
tin còn đấy vì cơ bản thì mình luôn quan
điểm là mình muốn kết thêm nhiều bạn mà
hình
ảnh nhưng mà kết bạn ở đây không phải
kết bạn trên Facebook đâu nha ông Các
ông cứ gửi các bạn trên Facebook là tôi
không bao giờ chứng nhận đâu bây giờ
Ừ tôi phải gặp mặt xong rồi Thân Thân tí
ra mới kết bạn toàn mấy người lại các
bạn trên Facebook
Em thấy chả tác dụng gì khác
ừ ừ
ở đây tôi trả lời được hai câu đúng
không
cái cách viết CV chắc là tôi
à mình mình xin phép để đến cuối buổi
hôm nay mình chia sẻ nhé em
đi câu cá không không không uống gì cả
ở
trong yootheme ai người toàn diện nhất
vậy
ở câu này cũng là một câu
anh nói ra đây hơn mất tình cảm anh em
tí
nha cho anh Tuấn đi à
Ý mình nói những điểm mạnh và điểm yếu
thì các bạn tự mò nhé để mạnh thì anh
Tuấn là người
khi viết bài hay vãi Viết văn hay
anh cứ giỏi ở mình đi làm Em lấy rồi thì
thấy anh đấy nhé
ở trên nhà tư duy trì sẽ thành Công Trứ
thân mình rồi kinh nghiệm Cũng hơn ở
nhưng mà sâu về một mảnh thì mình đang
tự tin mình hơn với anh đấy tạm thời Thế
à Nhưng mà anh ấy đã toàn diện theo kiểu
là biết hack ông anh em cho đi tìm anh
nghe nào Hình như biết hay không bị phạt
từ nói rồi
tự học lập trình tương đối ngôn ngữ lập
trình rất rộng
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
chú vịt hạn thì rất giỏi toán tư duy các
thứ con nhà mày ra các thứ
ừ ừ
em cũng cũng hài hước một hoạt giỏi
trẻ trâu cái kia thế
à À cũng có khả năng thuyết chị
các anh em khác thì
à Mình không thích lắm
từ Mina không nhớ của sếp anh em trong
tìm ra ảo ảnh hưởng quên mất su Hưng
à à Thế cơ à
Em
là người đầu tiên mình thân ở
sau khi mà vào công ty cho dù rõ ràng
nhà anh Tuấn mới về yêu mình đã thân anh
Hưng dần dần thách hơn
Ừ anh ấy dễ tính vãi
ở một con người dễ dãi để em anh nói ai
nữa nhiều quá anh xem video này thì em
nói anh sẽ mãi
yêu anh này nhưng tất cả những người
hướng nội dễ là anh nhiều hơn mỗi nhé ôm
mấy ông
Ê mấy ông a nói chuyện với người anh ấy
khóc
em đừng dễ dãi ở đây gì à
Nhớ đấy mấy ông từng nghe về cái vụ anh
đấy à cấp tròn quyền cho anh Tuấn kia
mới quen anh đấy ở
bên
grub
Cái hôm mà
À hôm khai giảng đấy con người dễ dãi à
Xin chào Bạn thích nhân Lê Thị
ừ ừ
à à
Mẹ con lại nhỉ
cho
anh Khánh anh Tráng anh Ngọc Chánh kia
anh ấy rất giỏi kỹ năng chuyên môn rất
giỏi tìm ra Bắc của mình để mặt phạt
À mà đây Đúng kiểu ông anh
giống như người anh trai với anh trai
của mình hơn đấy kia
a12 hay
mò Mình cũng là bắt lỗi mình giỏi vãi ừ
ờ ờ anh có hướng dẫn level trong khóa
này không thì ra làm khóa khóa này nữa
ra khỏi này nó khóa cơ bản Word cơ bản
mà ngon nhưng mà về sau mình sẽ dạy toàn
đội cái nói chung là mình sẽ rất toàn bộ
những kiến thức mà mình là
Khi mà mình có thể dạy ở trên kênh
YouTube mình và Chắc chia sẻ nhấn ngờ
chia sẻ nhiều hơn với người đó chưa chắc
là mình đã chuyên sâu bằng nhiều anh em
ở đây nên
nên nói chung là chia sẻ được ai ai thấy
ổn đi ôi đúng không đi
à à
em
hết hết sư câu ở nhỉ Ok hôm nay mình sẽ
bắt đầu buổi họp nha
đã muộn mất rồi Mười phút không
Ờ Ờ mình
Ừ mình ôn tập bằng bài tập hôm trước đi
cho ngon đi nha
thì mình sẵn vì sao mình có thể là
Ê hồi trước và mình dậy sinh viên mình
hồi đấy là Facebook còn lắm bức với đấy
mình cuối buổi mình thương anh chia sẻ
mấy cái
cho Cái Bấc của của
ở Facebook Ngạn cách để mà làm mấy cái
cũng từ lập trình mình biết được mình
cảm thấy rất hay ho chia sẻ sinh viên
anh bất ngờ Dương 7h Hùng nhiều nhé
nhưng mà nói chung à Vì sao có thể mình
sẽ áp dụng cái đấy thì các bạn cảm thấy
hào hứng hơn ở cuối buổi chúng mày cuối
buổi thấy nhàm chán quá Các bạn nào chưa
hết buồn mình mua
à à
khi tải
các bài hôm trước mình cảm thấy
các bạn đều gần như đều làm được chúng
ta bạn bài hôm trước tương đối dễ đúng
không ạ
à à
Anh đang Hôm trước mình để các bạn tự
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia vừa hỏi câu rất hay
thể thao tác trên chia sẻ cách thao tác
trên bàn phím nhanh để mã Hạn chế dùng
chuột đúng không Đúng mình cảm thấy à
các bạn
Em là dân kiểu công nghệ hoặc cả thậm
chí là dân văn phòng và Chung ấy thì các
bạn sử dụng bàn phím nhiều hơn con chuột
nên hãy nên để jira thay vì cứ ngồi gõ
rồi kéo lên cho tao gõ thì các bạn nên
gần như biết rất nhiều hiến pháp Giống
như mình hiện tại mình biết rất nhiều
phím tắt
chợ hoa cá tự tạo phím tắt cho mình
cho tôi con mẹ hôm nay vừa mới lên văn
phòng này Đấy con chuột mà một cụ Sáu về
Logitech
Ừ tự nhiên khoan chuột đấy em gì con
chua thấy có rất nhiều nút ở trên con
chuột mà tôi tạm rất nhiều phím tắt cho
con chuột đấy Em Như ạ Đấy
Logitech thực chị mà chúng tôi thích con
chuột hay vãi lôi kéo
Nó có cái cái để mà trình phím tắt này
Có ai giống như mình hết tại Nga với con
chuột mình nhé khoe khoe nhà hàng tí đây
đó là bấm một nút này chỉnh âm lượng này
tăng giảm âm lượng này kéo này tăng làm
lượng này bấm nút này để mà quay trở lại
cái gì đấy Bấm nút này để đấy
để mở các cửa sổ tab phân vân vân đấy
Nói chung à
khi
các bạn làm sao cho để mà cảm thấy các
bạn thích dùng máy tính và dùng máy tính
hiệu quả thì các bạn sẽ càng thích ngồi
máy tính hơn đúng không gần ngàn lần các
bạn sẽ hạn chế bị lừa cũng như tăng hiệu
suất với Vân đấy ừ ừ
ở
một con theo dõi mình từ năm 2019 nó kìa
ghê đấy
ừ ừ
Ừ thôi lại làm ăn rồi bạn có lại nha đầu
tiên mình tệ bạc mà rét thế bộ
Ờ ở đây mình nên ghi rõ có thể là con
vật chẳng hạn đúng không còn vật và động
vật bạn như thế có bạn như bà đến để
tiếng Anh như mình nghĩ là cứ dậy chung
nhiều bạn thì có để kiếm việc chữa mua
đi Ừ
khi mã này in Bear thôi Tạm thời thì
không nhìn báo chat nữa nha không mình
mất tập trung à
Anh tên này
nữa và
có bạn còn bảo để tên quốc tế cũng rất
là hay gì gì đấy không
Ừ nhưng mà mình cứ đọc hết đều đúng
không số chân có số chân này đúng không
số chân
à mà kiểu đi nuôi nó không có lại lẹ
được đúng không
em mình áp dụng check và defo defoe mình
cứ để cho là không đi à
à à
áo lót luôn trả không
Ê bà thực ra rất nhiều ông quên cái này
nhưng tôi làm luôn nó uống nước mà không
về để unique cho nó sẽ tên động vật nó
để gặp lại được thì ra thế ơi sai bởi vì
em mình đang để theo các động vật này
không phải tuần con mà đang ấy cả loài
chưa thế
à à
Nhớ lắm luôn Chẳng hạn tiếp nữa đúng
không ạ
ô môi trường sống này đúng không tạm
thời mình cái để môi trường sống đã
a a a
có ba con tuổi thọ cao nhất
đ.d AgNO3 tra
whey Thọ là kiểu tin nhắn ạ
À hôm trước của bạn để làm
ngày sinh và ngày mất vài Trưởng à
em không cần phải điều đấy mình cho loài
mà mới về từng con đúng không ạ
chị đã môi trường sống mình khuyên để
xuống quấy tí đệ mà vì sao mình không
tách làm hai bà không anh dạy các bạn
cách cách II
anh ấy cũng xong hết rồi đừng nói xong
rồi mình đưa mình sẽ tạo này cái check
ngon tiền tiên là check đi sẽ ra con
trên này mình tạo một cái biến trách là
chết tên em ạ
thì mình sẽ chắc độ dài tên
le tên là ví dụ ra lớn hơn hay chẳng gì
đấy đúng không
ờ ờ tpo
a checker
là số chẵn ngon chân diện check số chân
đã
có thể là
từ nhỏ hơn bao nhiêu đấy nhỏ hơn nha con
rết thì bà hai
mấy chân Đấy nó cứ Hà 100 thoải mái đi
gì đấy Có có bạn thì áp dụng luôn ở đây
đẹp hay nghi in thì là hại hoặc là small
I là nó sẽ kiểu giới hạn với kiểu này bé
rồi em mình cứ vui ước ngay cho
Nếu mình không biết đúng không rước nghe
cũng được không sao
tiếp theo để đã tuổi thọ
à à
ê ê số chân từ này vẫn phải lớn hơn lớn
không ấy nhỉ quên lại
nhưng không Này E này nó
anh em
đấy tuổi thọ
lớn không
anh còn bao nhiêu tuổi thì tùy đúng
không ạ
một số chân chẵn á á
anh không Mình nhớ có con nào cho nó bị
lẻ Hình như có nghệ nên con gì đấy
thì kệ thôi còn lý ở các bạn muốn thực
sự được 1 số chấm chẵn thì thì da mình
chưa thử vủ
vụ đấy bây giờ như chia đây là chia lấy
dư là
a a
device Diva và chia Divide
nhé Khuya rồi
Em thử nhé
Ừ cái này liên quan bên lập trình tí nữa
ý là cái này nó quyết định nó trả về nó
là
ừ ừ
ở đây chia lấy dư vẫn là theo phần trăm
thôi
mình sẽ có khái niệm đây là em số chân
phần trăm
hay bằng không hết tất cả sau tất cả
chia lấy dư
Ờ mà bằng không Nghĩa là nghĩa là dư
không
A gọi như là nhãn Nói chung à Cái này để
lấy số chẵn như thế
chia lấy dư mỏng ví dụ sự 3 chia 2 dư 1
còn 4 chia hai rước cốc nhận đúng không
ạ Con không có chân
Nghe ca nhạc đừng quên quên quên quên
lời Loan bằng nó quên vừa nãy mình để
biết để câu không ở đây rồi
anh nói đơn không chịu chia phần trăm
hai ngày dư thì nó bằng Không vẫn hết
đúng không Ok
đi đái tiếp theo là môi trường sống thì
ra môi trường sống thì mình sẽ không
005 cái chết chủ đề đây cả thì mình sẽ
làm sau các bạn sẽ hiểu tại sao lại mình
tạo bàn nha I walk
through có bảy con nhưng hơi lười nên là
mình cứ
i ee con theo theo đề bài đâu nhé
Anh tên số chân tuổi thọ
môi trường sống này
này à
khi con bún chân
Cú này ạ
ở tuổi thọ
t20 Đà Nẵng
khi mua sắm là chính nhà bạn ạ
Đấy thêm con nữa là
à à
có gì
Lê Hoàng Thượng mèo
Ơ
con này Chín Kiếp à chí không
số chi tiết cho số 9 đi đã 2 con
khi mua trứng sống thêm Con ơi con cá đi
có bạn thắc mắc 10 vụ Nếu mà số chân để
mặc định địa phô dùng như cả không có
chân đi sẽ lại để iPhone như này thì sẽ
hiểu là nhập
ừ ừ
Ừ ừ Mình nhớ có con ba chân không nhớ
con gì
ừ ừ
ờ ờ thì bà đây sẽ rưới nước đúng không
đã lại thế
đấy hai hai con 20 chưa chẳng thế
xổ số kon đại chắc chỉ ngay đùa
xin lỗi
à À đúng rồi
a
nhong nhong nhong nhong mình để không
nhập sữa chân là nó như chị lỗi Xin lỗi
để bốn đây ở đây là ở tuổi
top 10 năm đi sửa thế
từ trước tiên hả Cá mình à cá tây lại
thấp quá đúng không Ok mình sẽ cá nhà đi
cả cưới đấy thế là nó dài đúng không ok
à
ờ ờ
snacks cao
hệ thống kê có bao nhiêu con vì nó liên
quan đến không đến
do động vật
ờ ờ
A Goodbye treo
Ô Môi trường đúng không môi trường sớm
nhà mình có thể lấy luôn ở môi trường
sống ở đây đã
đi đái thì mình xảy ra như này đúng
không Mình nên để Adidas Nó để tên cho
nó đến cạn thì ông mình sẽ lách thì mình
luôn xuống dòng này nhìn nó rõ này Đây
là xổ con nữa
em
không nhận
bộ phim thứ tự nhà này công nhận nhé IDM
bình thường phải chạy đoàn anh nhé
có điều người nhà em ạ
à Anh nhầm nhầm xin lỗi xin lỗi xin lỗi
gì nào nhau quá Hôm nay mình công nhận
mình cứ bị ngáo ngáo gì thông cảm cho
anh mới ngủ dậy
a a vừa rồi mọi người thấy vẫn chạy được
rồi kìa nó á Adidas này lấy áp dụng được
cho cả bà a cho vì sau có thể mình sẽ đề
cập đến các bạn sau A
à À quên thống kê con bao nhiêu chân 4
chân nhé Cái này phải
ở hai bên anh ừ công nhận hôm nay mình
nhé cái thôi
chứ đỡ xin lỗi à
hệ thống kê sporty a where
là số chẵn này làm sao tôi tỉnh lại
thích đây xin lỗi các bạn đó được đúng
không ạ
à mà hệ thống kê trèo từng gửi số chân
đúng không
số 7 số chân
mẹ không táo Mình chỉ có cốt đâu mà mua
A chạy
Anh đang số chân không thì có một con
đúng không xuống chân à
a A4 có hai con đúng rồi mà đúng không
thống kê tuổi thọ trung bình đấy thì
mình sẽ copy này theo môi trường sống
nữa đúng không Thì mình sẽ ra môi trường
sống sau đó đi AVG
ở tuổi thọ đúng không Chú Thỏ
ca nhạc tuổi thọ trung bình ở
ở đó thì mình sẽ ra được thì thọ trung
bình đến nhiên là con cá cược thì nó có
mỗi một con nên này ra đấy nó Bằng chính
nó đúng không
lấy ra ba con có tuổi thọ cao nhất
Ừ thì à ký thể select appa sao phone
động vật
order bang số điện thoại bà giảm dần
nghe em ạ
thì mình sẽ lấy ra
có những con sắp xếp theo tuổi thọ từ
cao nhất đến thấp đúng không
Đương nhiên bây giờ còn 13 con thì như
là nó sẽ như này đúng không
ừ ừ
à à
Cho tôi hỏi mình chi đó mình sẽ đề cập
đến lỗi và hướng giải quyết của lỗi đấy
ngay cho các bạn đôi khi chính mình cũng
gây lỗi mà cố tình gây ra lỗi thì mà chỉ
các bạn à hướng này quyết là gì Các bạn
yên tâm đi
ờ ờ một là cách ở như thế này đúng không
Hôm trước mình có đi cập dịch vụ là các
bạn tra Limit họp xét ý là giả sữa là
mình muốn lấy á
anh ở một con nhưng mà bộ bỏ qua ví dụ
là sự mình muốn lấy con cá cược cả cả
nghĩa là mình bỏ qua còn đầu tiên này
mình cái con con thứ hai nhưng mình mình
chỉ lấy 10 nó khái niệm về Limit offset
và giới hạn và bỏ hoa thì mình sẽ tra
đấy nhá đến bị offset-aware này
anh kia miệng mà tra cụ thể hơn ví dụ là
sự là em của anh sẽ vỡ rồi chẳng hạn
đúng không cha này
ở một mình cha ra một cái trang xem lại
nhé
xe máy
ở đây
em không có mẹ máy kia à
anh xem lại nhé Ngày mai anh qua em rồi
có mình cha đâu nhé
em không có bảy cái này
à à
AE xaj cronus nhìn có khả năng đây đây
đây nó sẽ như thế này
300 mình nhớ mà quan trọng là mình hướng
dẫn các bạn để tra lại thôi mình nhiều
lắm đây này thì cách viết nó sẽ là
offset nhà có copy về đúng không Vẫn on3
này cái này nó xếp sao rồi đúng không Bỏ
cái top 3 đi ra top 3 này nó rất mông
lung à để các bạn sang mai que O nó sẽ
không hiểu lắm thì kêu mình sẽ treo
offset Theo bạn giới thiệu học sat là bỏ
qua bao nhiêu bạn ghi và sức mình bỏ qua
một bản ghi ạ mình thì iCloud của cô dâu
thêm ít Thìa nó đều nhận nhé không Anh
ngồi cả
gì đấy
A và mình sẽ là cách là lấy bao nhiêu
tháng 1 là lấy bao nhiêu tháng đầu tiên
này hãy bỏ qua gì đấy thì mình cứ phớt
nha đi nó dễ hiểu Đừng bỏ qua một để lấy
một chẳng ạ lại chạy thử nhé mày ra con
cá cược đúng không Đấy tha sẽ cái này nó
sẽ hiểu theo máy của em mình biết nó sẽ
ngắn và dễ hiểu hơn Hoài hãy viên hơi bị
trừu tượng một tí đó là mình sẽ định đi
mít một họp Z1 còn viết ngắn hơn nữa thì
nó sẽ lít 1,1 live
à
Còn nếu mà không có xét thì đương nhiên
ấy là là sẽ hiểu là không bỏ qua thằng
Hảo lấy hết đúng không Đấy xe máy của em
Ừ ok Nói chung à cưng tâm tương đối hiệu
xong hết bài hôm trước cho anh anh gửi
bài hôm trước cơ bản
bây giờ xanh buồn Hôm nay đó là tách nó
ra 2 bảng cho dễ quản lý thì mình lại
cảm thấy không muốn chữa
mà thôi Mình cứ chữ bài này trước là
nhanh các bạn nhé thì đầu tiên là mình
crack cable
Em à mình phải toán ở đây Cái này nó
liên quan đến tí thì cách thiết kế cơ sở
niệm đã đó là mình phải chiều mối quan
hệ một nó
nn11 nó là gì
ờ ờ đây
các mối quan hệ
n&n nó
mối quan hệ nó rất cơ bản ở trong nhà cơ
sở điệu thì mình cứ nói qua bãi khái
theo theo cách mình thường phải dậy đó
là thằng nào sinh ra trước mà có trước
đi đái kia tan là thằng cha đúng không
Vợ thằng ấy phải được tạo trước
cho ví dụ ở đây Các bạn thấy là bán
động vật đúng không ạ
anh với môi trường là hai thứ mà là có
thể tách ra được bởi vì là sao các bạn
xem được đấy em
Ừ cái nào nó hay lặp lại ở đây bạn thấy
tên lính bên không gặp lại được rồi má
Không lặp lại được số chân các bạn cũng
phải làm lại được nếu các bạn tạo là hằn
bạc là bạn số chân thì các chàng nghĩa
gì Mấy tuổi thọ Thế các bạn không quen
Tách cái này ra nhưng mà môi trường sống
như các bạn này liên cách là tại sao vì
sau mình quản lý do xưởng mình thêm một
mình muốn giờ sự là Ừ cái này nó lặp đi
lặp lại này là sử các bạn có hàng trăm
con ở trong nhà hai trăm con ở trên cạn
em ạ Cái từ trên cạn đấy là bịp lại rất
nhiều sau đó thì về sau các bạn muốn đổi
tên cái từ trên cạn này thành từ thiệu
ví dụ là lưỡng hư hay gì gì đấy thì các
bạn phải đổi tên đồng nghĩa là update
cho cây đây ví dụ lịch sử đây mình đã sử
mình muốn đổi tên trong nhà hàng trên
cạnh đó là ngon thì mình lại phải update
động vật
anh sex môi trường sống bằng
ở trên cạn Chẳng hạn thế Mình phải cập
nhật cho tất cả
khi tất cả những cái que
Ô Môi trường sóng
đi bằng trong nhà
này anh cấp Nhiều tất cả Thế có bao
nhiêu động vật đang ngồi trong nhà vua
sẽ bên hết thành trên cạn nó sẽ rất dễ
bị nặng cái hợp việc cơ nhỡ đâu có một
bạn nào đó mới là một động vật nào đó
chưa được cập nhật và nhớ lỗi
cho ví dụ Giả sử tự nhiên trong nhà hàng
đốt đấy mình thường muốn cháu cách như
này em ạ tự nhiên là một con động vật nó
sẽ không được cập nhật hàng trên cạn
loại thế thì cách đấy rất khó làm quản
lý cái môi trường sống nữa ạ
em và nó bị lặp lại dữ liệu chữ nó lặp
lại nó sẽ rất nặng đấy đấy khái niệm về
việc là cái Wow thì nó sẽ
a khái niệm mà nó sẽ kiểu làm
để hạn chế việc thay đổi dữ liệu có vấn
đề
anh và cũng như là giảm tải sự dư thừa
dữ liệu như này đây gọi dư thừa dữ liệu
sẽ hoàn toàn hai cái này có thể biến
thành 1 và 2 chẳng ạ Mình quy ước trong
nhà là một dưới nước là hai cháu ạ thì
mình cứ thế mà mình Điền thôi thì nó sẽ
dễ hơn giống như là cái giới tính của
trước mình làm đi
đi thi à à
Ừ thì đây mình sẽ tách nó làm 2 bảng Ok
thì mình sẽ phải hiểu là bản nào đối tao
trước thì đây các bạn sẽ thấy là một môi
trường sẽ có nhiều động vật một môi
trường sẽ có n động vật
và một động vật thì thuộc một ngôi
trường ra xử thế nếu mà con lưỡng cư thì
nó hẳn là môi trường động cơ đi 2 giờ xử
thế nó sẽ mua thì thì bạn sẽ thấy là đây
mối quan hệ 1-n thì
có chìa mình sẽ phải tạo bảng môi trường
một trước và thằng động vật nó sẽ là
thằng con vẫn đang mưa chưa Thế thế
à à
anh nói bé quá
Hôm nay mình cứ bị sao ấy Tra tấn không
tâm trạng mình sẽ ổn thôi chào hôm nay
Em không biết giải thích nha Nhưng mà
con người mà kiểu gì sẽ có ngày này ngày
kia
đi
Hãy cho Bây giờ mình tạm một cái bảng
môi trường sống đúng không ạ
Ừ thì sẽ có mã kia in VNPT tự động tăng
vẫn thế đúng không tên nhờ vào tra
50 Note Mun
unique theo Chánh trung tuyến của môi
trường đúng không
khóa chính các thứ sau khi mã này à
Ừ Rồi sau đó thì lại rút
bạn ngon Nó thấy bồ động vật Tại sao
phải đốt
số 1 là lốp hay là các bạn phải mất công
Xóa cột môi trường sống đi để đội nó
thành nhà mã môi trường sống các thứ thứ
thì mình cứ tạm rốt vào đi đã nhé mình
sẽ viết lại cái bảng Grand cái bồ này
xuống dưới này cho bạn với anh dung này
đây sẽ làm mã môi trường sống
mà mình phải theo quy tắc như thế nào
gửi theo quy tắc đó là
Ờ Ờ cái này là in thì càng hẹn mất buộc
phải đi mày à
Ừ hai cái này là gì đấy Cái này bắt buộc
phải như thế nó luôn Ôi này và không ai
mình sẽ học Khoa Ngoại ngữ sẽ khái niệm
tôi niki như thế này con kia mình sẽ có
đã cụt mã môi trường sống
repellent
là nối đến cái bảng nào nối mạng môi
trường sống
xe
máy quét mã này chưa
áo dài nhỉ Mua Martin giai đoạn nhưng mà
thế này dễ hiểu đúng không vào loại này
anh nói
Hình như cái này cháu mua tròn nữa à
Anh bảo đồ đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ sau đó em Ý xuất bình thường nhưng mà
bây giờ này mình sẽ thay nó là
mã môi chùm sống như này
ngon nhưng mà trước đấy hình như mình đã
nói đó là mình phải có thằng cha lãi rồi
mày có thằng con đúng không Mà mình sẽ
phải Ace sốt trước
môi trường sống trước đã mình sẽ có
chung tên loa này Alo lại
nó
trong à
à à
ở
ngoài trời đã xử thế Ngon Insert
ở đây
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ ăn sắp lại cái
thế này để hẳn xuống dưới nhé em xuống
dưới này dễ nhìn này
bây giờ mã môi trường sống ở đây mình sẽ
à mình sẽ mình sẽ phải chợ sẽ like xem
lại thực sự đã
for môi trường sống Xem thời sự nó là
120 mình tránh việc đi bừa nhé một hai
nhà đúng hãy Sao tự nhiên mình phải nói
việc gì vừa đây vì nó nghe nhé Bởi vì
nếu nhờ sự các bạn nấu sòng đi thì mã
bạn sẽ tự động tăng các bạn không biết
các bạn là thừa vụ đấy chưa ạ
Ở nhà chẳng hạn
à Mà không phải đi hết sao nhầm nhầm
Em tán anh sẽ lại
a mã vẫn sẽ thành để lên nó sẽ la34 thì
cái mã ở dưới này nó bắt buộc phải Khớp
nó không phải là một hai được để duy
nhất thế là cứ khi bạn in sơ mà bị nhầm
gì đấy
khi bị nhầm ý thì các bạn giúp là sự đây
có thừa một cục gì đó chẳng hạn như này
nó nhầm đúng không như này nó sẽ báo lỗi
Đúng không thì các bạn khi mày sót lại
thì mã nó sẽ bị tăng lên rất nhiều
chị xem mẹ 34 đúng không ạ
à à
Ở đây các bạn lên hẹn Thế nên hạn nó là
sáu bảy chữ nó không còn là kiểu 4 thành
556 cái gì đấy Các bạn thấy là một khi
máy in số sai đó mã nó vẫn sẽ tự động
tăng lên thành ra là các bạn luôn phải
sẽ lách lại để mà biết chắc chắn chắc
chắn là cái cái mã đấy Đúng Tại sao bởi
bây giờ mình thường nhập mã sai bạn sẽ
thấy báo lỗi
bây giờ xưa mình nhằm một đúng không lý
sót mỗi Cún đang cho chạy lại đói Các
bạn thấy nó ràng buộc liên quan đến khoa
ngoại nó ràng buộc vào nó sẽ báo lỗi như
này gì chưa
em có bạn thắc mắc với mình là nếu mà em
tạo bà em không có phone kỳ này để nối
sang bạn như thế này nhé Em vẫn có một
mã mã môi trường sống em chạy vẫn được
cái Rốt cuộc cái này điểm gì đúng không
cái này chấm như làm các bạn thấy ở đây
Nó là một cái con trên một cái răng buộc
mà hôm trước mình từng học con trên ràng
buộc rồi nó cốt là để kiểm tra việc và
mã này bắt buộc phải tồn tại ở trong Ba
bạn này đúng không đây Thế bây giờ bắt
buộc các bạn phải nhập mã giữa đúng thì
nó mới nhận
Ê bà mẹ bốn nha trở lại chạy
ở đó Ngủ chưa
ở đời mình thự select sao
from động vật thiên hạ xem lại kết bạn
sẽ Thái Lan bây giờ mà anh sẽ ba bốn
đứng yên là mã 34 như thế này các bạn sẽ
chị sẽ thấy là ạ Mình chẳng biết thằng
Ba là thằng nào thằng 4 lần nào cả thì
bé hôm nay ngoài việc học con kia khó
ngoại mình sẽ biết thêm bên cho biết qua
một chút thôi buổi sau mình sẽ đi sâu
bài tập các thứ về do do nó rất nặng
phải mất khá nhiều buồn à
anh
làm sao để reset các mã đó kia
thì các bạn cái bản thân cái mã này các
bạn biết vì sau nó là một cái kiểu
anh gọi lại nó nhưng phải Index các bạn
vì sau giúp nó hoa cà dùng khái niệm
chăn kết ừ ừ
à à
a Joy môi trường sống này on môi trường
sống chấm Mã bán động vật trầm mã môi
trường sống đây tiền tài kinh tụng
ngờ mình sẽ không ở phía tắt
từ
dễ gây nhầm lẫn khi mà do như thế này
nếu bạn sẽ thấy da nó sẽ hiển thị ra cá
he
thì nó sẽ gần như là hiển thị ra cái bạn
cái bàn đấy ở bên phải luôn đúng không
Ừ thế bạn này nó sẽ kiểu ứng cái cột này
ứng với cột này cột này ứng con này
không đến nối với nhau như thế này tự do
mà tác dụng như thế chưa hỏi dựa trên
hai cục này nối với nhau này
A
và đương nhiên mà thực tế các bạn không
cần phải cơn nối như này với trên chính
cột khói ngoại đã từng có bạn bị nhầm có
bạn ấy bị nhầm như thế này bạn nói mỗi
một mãi nha cả vì vừa rồi giờ sự Các bạn
thấy mình bấm cái cái ID cái tu này nó
chưa loát lại nên nó chứng nhận được cái
cục này của mình đã nhận mỗi cột mã thôi
đúng không Đấy thành ra
để thành xa lạ
vì nó gợi ý mỗi cột này ra xương mình
chạy con này thì các bạn thấy thời gian
nó vẫn chạy được ngay nhưng nó không
đúng nữa vì mã này là mã này là mã của
động vật chứng khoa mã của môi trường
sống nó không nó không đúng đã
em này cái thứ nhất cái thứ hai là có
bạn hỏi mình là em không muốn nghỉ thị
cột mã mã này nữa sự em không cần em chỉ
một lấy tên của môi trường sống thôi
đúng không Thì mình sẽ có khái niệm là
mình C lách những cái thứ mình cần lấy
rồi đúng không sửa là mình muốn lấy
động vật chấm mã này động và 300 tên này
động vật chấm số chẵn là
tuổi thọ lại Vân Vân này và cuối cùng là
môi trường sống chấm Tên đấy Tại mình sẽ
lấy kiểu như này
Ừ thì nó xảy ra đúng những cái thử minh
cần lấy thôi gì chưa
và đương nhiên là các bạn thấy là cái
cột tên nó vẫn đang bị trùng cột tên nó
ngon thì các bạn Thể ạ Alice Ở đây là
tên môi trường sống hay cái gì đấy mà
đúng không ạ
à à
Em ăn chưa
ừ ừ
Ê
thằng Dũng nó
Ừ thì nước này được vừa rồi các bạn học
qua thì có thể nó mới Nhưng mà vẫn chưa
đau đầu lắm Chẳng qua mới thôi Bây giờ
mình bắt đầu sang cái đau đầu
các bạn thử nghe nhé em
ờ ờ
ở đầu tiên là khái niệm để mà sâu hơn
một cái này nó là khái niệm về quy tắc
chuẩn hóa cơ sở liệu giống như vừa rồi
mình có đề cập đó là các bạn không phải
tự nhiên tách ra thành hai bạn như thế
cũng như là
giảm bớt hội nào đi Giảm mỡ của nào hay
các thứ khi nó có những quy tắc của nó
cái này liên quan là toán học một tí hồi
đấy mình phải học toán về cấu trúc dữ
liệu giải thuật nhưng mà mình không dậy
mấy cái chuyên sau mình bảo mình sẽ
không dạy chuyên sâu các bạn ở đây như
mình sẽ giảm thiểu nhưng mà ai mà thực
sự muốn kiểu Ai đang học càng cái này mà
cảm thấy là hồi học đại học mình có về
không được nghe hai à Rồi học đại học
Mình quên được ạ thì các bạn sao Google
lại cái chuẩn hóa cơ sở liệu các bạn đạt
nhé các bạn này nói rất hay như bạn ấy
không có ví dụ gì cả nên là mình đã phải
tự tạo Ví dụ ở chính mình và bây giờ thử
nói xem các bạn có hiểu không nhé
A tại mình đang có người này cột
đó là sự Đây là phần mềm đẹp mà
thầy hiệu trường yêu cầu mình làm một
cái cơ sở dữ liệu để quản lý sinh viên
kèm với điểm của bạn đấy Chẳng
Ồ thông tin sinh viên kèm với điểm
24 tuổi này Hà Nội này
tới lớp là lập trình đi nên môn là s AD
lần thi lần 1 này được 5 bia mà chẳng À
mà thôi được 3 điểm đi để mà mình có thì
lại này Ừ tự nhiên là toàn bộ đồng này
phải lặp lại để mà nó thay là lần 2 này
và lần này lên 5 điểm đấy đấy các bạn sẽ
thấy à
em chỉ với 1 bạn tới lòng thôi
Ừ nó khác nhau ở mỗi lần gì rồi Hoặc
thậm chí là điểm vẫn giống nhau hay nhất
thế giới
ế quá
Ừ thì các bạn bị lặp lại dữ liệu rất
nhiều đúng không
cho các bạn thấy thế đúng không ạ
a tiếp theo của sự bạn Tiến Tuấn
em 20 tuổi Hà Nội này cũng được trình
cùng ai kia rồi cũng thi với mình
cho mẹ 5 điểm trở lại thì các bạn thấy
lặp lại đây rất nhiều thông tin không
Ừ đúng
Ừ thì cách nào để mà mình hạn chế lọc
như lai cũng như là để về sau mình sửa
quê quán của bạn Long là sửa thành Hồ
Chí Minh ở ạ thì mình không phải mất
công sửa lại tất cả những chỗ nào nhắn
này bạn Long đấy cũng như là ở đây là sự
có 25 mà đây bị lặp lại bạn ghi này chết
đúng không có 25 vì sao Đúng không đấy
thế nên à
Ừ thì nên làm đây bài toán là thứ nhất
là mình phải thêm cội nó cột mã mã sinh
viên
phân biệt là sửa đây
như này thì mình à mới hiểu là Cập nhật
cập nhật cho quê quán của bạn Long có mã
là một thì phải cập nhật hết chứ không
phải cập nhật theo tên người tên có thể
nhầm không
à à
xe tải thì
Ừ thì nhớ là mình có duyên quần mã ok
rồi nó ngon thứ hai là các bạn thấy vẫn
bị lặp lại dữ liệu mà đúng không thích
và mình nên làm nha các bạn nên tách
từng phần ra một thông tin của sinh viên
ra thông tin của những cái gì đó ra thì
bây giờ mình sẽ được anh nhá Ờ thì sẽ
tách ra 1 bảng sinh viên em ạ sinh viên
thì sẽ quét mã này của tên này mình để
mãi một này Long này mã 2tuấn đây
sau đó đây là tuổi đúng không tuổi này
mình đi không có dấu theo như bản mình
không nên lưu dấu mà nhớ đấy Hay bố này
U20 chẳng hạn
như có ở quê toàn nữa này bê xuống này
để Hồ Chí Minh đi Hà Nội chọn ra xử thế
là sử thấy đúng không đấy
à Mà lớp của mình mẹ tách là giả sử là ở
đây mình có
các bạn nữa mất tiền anh nè
à à 19 tuổi
ở Hà Nội này
ạ Bạn ấy học bên á
ý an toàn thông tin này
mà an toàn
Ồ thông tin mua à
khoa học môn khác đi buôn về hack không
trở lại đúng không Cứ thứ thứ này đi
Chừng nào thì các bạn thấy là rõ ràng à
lớp đây là tại rất nhiều đúng không Mình
tách hạt lớp da này lớp này Mãi Tên đấy
lập trình này an toàn thông tin này kiểu
ngay
Ê bà như thế thì ở đây tách A như thế
này thì hai thằng này nó nối với nhau
kiểu gì đúng không thì các bạn lại thấy
bài toán đây đó làm bài toán một lời
thôi Nó là một lớp chứa n bạn sinh viên
đúng không em chưa thì ở đây tức là mình
sẽ hiểu là một sinh viên sẽ có thêm mã
lớp bạn lớp
là quê quan Xin lỗi quê quán mã lớp đây
là 11 và bạn anh này không Bạn anh này
chị sẽ
Hà Nội này sẽ mở lớp là 2 giờ Xứ Huế
are you
em có bạn còn muốn tách nhỏ hơn ra nữa
cơ Ờ bạn đấy muốn rách cả Giả sử đây
các bạn được tách luôn cả quê quán ra
cũng cũng được cũng được
các bạn phát ra cũng kiểu tương tự lớp
này em muốn chưa nhỏ đó nữa em có thể
chia nhỏ ra đây là
ở quê quán đúng không quê quán sang đây
đây mã đi Hà Nội Hồ Chí Minh Đúng không
thì đây sẽ là mã quê quán
đây là
211 và xử thế đúng không
chị đánh à
ừ ừ
ở đây đấy để một cái nữa nhé tiếp theo
còn gì nhỉ đi
à À đúng rồi
hôm trước còn nhiều bạn hỏi này nó xử ở
đây mình chuẩn là thường là mình thấy
hồi trước mình thường hay đệ của các bạn
lưu là nó lại cả họ và tên này nghĩa Nam
Long lại chẳng ạ
Đây là Mạnh Tuấn nó trả
Lê
Văn anh ạ chưa
Ê bà các bạn về sau nếu mà muốn thống kê
những bạn à Muốn tìm kiếm những bạn tới
Long ra vẫn tìm kiếm được tiêu biểu có
thể dùng các thơ thứ nhưng mà lọc thế
rất là mất công thay vì ngay lúc đầu
mình lọc ra ngay từ đầu kiếm thằng để mà
làm thì các bạn sẽ
chị
sẽ làm như thế này
Ừ nó tách hẳn cột thọ của tên lắm bởi vì
bài toán về quy tắc chuẩn hóa này là một
một cột nó chỉ chứa đơn chị là một giá
trị thôi Đây là cả họ cả Tây mất rồi
giống như một địa chỉ các bạn thế địa
chỉ nó là ba chị mất rồi ở trường như
giá trị mua rồi đấy nghĩa là bao gồm cả
số nhà tên phố này tên quận tên tên gì
gì đó Tên tỉnh có thứ gì đó nữa mà cái
ở Đại học Nguyễn lại này
cả
họ nhà họ gì uống sữa cho tôi về mạng
cho đi đại khái như thế đúng không ngoan
này anh này nhé tách biệt ra ngay được
chưa
Ừ mình không nói về là chuẩn mấy chuẩn
máy đây nhé Mình không đề cập các bạn
trang chủ động gặp lại thôi mình sẽ nói
về những quy tắc để quy tắc thế thôi
chưa nó sẽ những cái tắm nghe mình ghi
lại các bạn cho bạn nhiều nhé á
Chợ Tốt nhất là phải
đơn Chị này
là thứ hai là
loại bỏ trùng lặp
sàn bảng mới lại khá như thế tại Khánh
như thế rồi bởi vì thực sự các bạn để
mày hiểu được để làm được cái bàn mới
này các bạn phải học liên quan tí kế
toán để mà nó hiểu nó là nó là hình thức
suy ra cơ hàng ngày có được sinh ra bởi
thằng này không thấy đau đầu cực nghe
mình không cố đi cập ở đây mình sẽ nhìn
thấy những cái nó Trung Lập thì mình Thế
Tống nó ra được bạn mới dễ quản lý thì
mình làm à anh nghe theo dễ hiểu hơn mà
không ạ
ở đó tiếp theo là một loại bỏ
những cái có thể tính toán
tại sao bây giờ sử tự nhiên ở đây mình
có một cột là điểm trung bình ở ạ
địa chỉ rõ ràng Ở đây các bạn thể là hai
môn này cộng lại điểm trung bình mình là
ba
anh ở đây bốn đi thì đây là bao sinh năm
này à
thì các bạn thấy là rõ là cột điểm trung
bình này nó được tính toán dựa trên 2
cột là dựa trên cột khác để tình cảm ra
thì cái này không nên
300 hôm nay đau đầu sẽ tốt đau đầu chứng
tỏ não các bạn đang đục dậy mình thấy
thế Không sai
thì các bạn đừng có thấy đau đầu quá các
bạn bỏ cuộc rồi đúng không yên tâm mình
sẽ dạy mấy cái khó này cho trả nó không
phải là trong một buổi như này là xong
buổi sau mình sẽ nhớ lại buổi sáng nữa
mình nhắc lại
đến buổi thứ ba thứ tư thì các bạn cũng
sẽ vẫn đau đầu đấy nhưng mà bớt đau đầu
hơn khi mở đầu í
Ừ thì à các bạn không nên lưu lại những
cột có thể tình toàn như này cái thứ
nhất thứ hai giống tuổi lại thế mình bà
các bạn nên lưu ngày sinh tại sao mọi
việc Cái tuổi này nó tính toán dựa trên
năm sinh cộng với
A5 Hiện tại thì năm sinh thì nên là cứ
năm sau nó lại phải tính lại một lần
chưa anh
kia mình sẽ phải lưu lại ngày sinh thôi
đấy bà cột điểm trung bình này mình sẽ
phải tự dùng hàm hàm để tính trung bình
các bạn nhớ chứ đúng không Chứ không
không lưu thêm một cột để mà thi toán gì
chưa
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi có video để xem lại mà đúng
không Các bạn không hiểu xem đi xem lại
mà không hiểu được nữa đừng nghĩ mình
kém Vội có thể do thầy kém ho mình không
hợp thấy vân vân
từ trước khi tất cả mọi người cùng hiểu
mà mình không hiểu mình mới bắt đầu nghĩ
lại việc mình kém đúng không ạ đi đái
gần mình sẽ lưu lại ngày sinh mà chẳng ạ
2k
1999 đã ra xử thế đúng không ạ
ở đó tiếp theo còn gì nữa đầy loại tiền
Môn Đúng không Ở đây Cái này mới bắt đầu
xanh lúa này cái xác định là đủ rồi
Ừ Để tôi hỏi các ông nha Vậy là không
110 ông rồi đấy Ok đúng không Ờ
là một sinh viên
Anh chỉ được bao nhiêu 1
anh hả trả trả lời đi đến vợ đến giờ
tương tác rồi thì trả lời xem một sinh
viên thi được bao nhiêu mối
ê nờ more more Ok ngon ạ
it1 môn một môn nhé được thi bởi bao
nhiêu sinh viên
à à
à 24 tiền chỉ à
em có lời sinh viên không Ok
nó mối quan hệ 11 sinh viên và 11 N sinh
viên và nó Môn Đúng không chỉ các bạn sẽ
thấy là tức là thằng sinh viên chẳng
phải thằng cha của thằng môn cũng như
Nhược Bạn Hồng môn cũng chồng lại là
hoàng chào sinh viên hay hàng nó sẽ là
bằng cấp nhau và hai hàng có thể sinh ra
cùng nhau đúng không
ở bài đầu tiên thì mình sẽ phải nói qua
vụ tự nhiên phải lò quay vụ tra đấy cha
con đây làm gì được kìa chuẩn ra phải
như thế này
xe tải love phải được sinh ra trước quê
quán phải được sinh ra trước và thằng
này nó sẽ kế thừa Mã từ cái thằng mấy
thằng cha này nhưng hành môn thì nó sinh
ra ngay bên cạnh đó sẽ là mã
ba mẹ buồn không
à à
ở lại như này thôi và nó sẽ lại kia trả
lại hai này hack này chắc là xử thế đúng
không này nó như này nó thôi
A và hai thằng nợ rồi như thế này nó sẽ
sinh em một bạn đúng không có phải trời
được rồi chúng không bạn đấy giờ xử là ở
bảng điểm thi đúng không
đặt tên nói kiểu bảng điểm thi em ạ Nó
là trung gian kết nối giữa tháng này
tháng này không để mà kết nối hai hành
với nhau thì xanh này nó phải lưu lại mã
của cả hai thằng Thường thì mình lại Ưu
tiên những cái thằng mà ạ
đi lặp lại nhiều lên trước thằng này đến
sau hay Quan trọng là thằng này thằng
môn là quan trọng hơn là sinh viên Bởi
vì môn đó lặp lại nhiều hơn Anh Sinh
Viên
anh em không rõ ràng là một môn thi và
nhiều sinh viên mà không về các bạn muốn
nó lại nhiều hơn
thì mình sẽ mã môn này để quan điểm mình
không nhá chưa các bạn thử ra để tên sắp
xếp tinh sắp xếp theo thứ tự của cột
loạn lên bây giờ sử của tên trước một mã
nó vẫn nó vẫn chạy không gì sai cả được
chưa để quan điểm thôi
à à Kệ cậu
à à
Ẩm Thực ra lúc đầu mình định kẻ kẻ đấy
nhờ các bạn thấy là mình nãy giờ mình
đổi đổi thứ tự nó loạn hết cả lên nên
mình cũng lười ăn
Mở bài một trong những phím tắt nữa
không để ý tôi đang bấm phím tắt để mặc
nó ra nhau
Anh Đỗ biết về phím tắt gì luôn tôi bấm
vào cái chỗ này xong rồi tôi cậu Anh ở
mấy cái chỗ kia tôi chỉ việc bôi xong
rồi tôi bấm 11 phím thôi sẽ tự động
đi lặp lại cái á thể thao tác của tôi
trên trên mấy cái này
nhà bán tôi bởi béo người biết nhiều khi
tóc vào
us5 là nó lại sao mà F4 thì ông ấy S4 S4
áp dụng được trong Excel Word này các
thứ thứ đấy
Chị linh tinh bê cái gì
ở đó là mấy ông trùm thao tác cái gì bất
kỳ thao tác gì ông muốn lặp lại thao tác
format đẩy lên lên chỗ khác thì ông dùng
F4
Em ngủ chưa
ừ đấy thế mấy ông chứ còn mấy không
không không tìm hiểu sau đúng không
cho tôi tìm hiểu về mấy cái phím tắt
trước khi học lập trình cơ nên mấy ông
không đổ tại lắm ông học được trình nên
mới biết được tôi chuyên Excel hơn mấy
người đấy chứ
thơ Nguyễn tiếp theo là lần thi đúng
không
bà tiếp theo là điều gì chưa đó mình sẽ
luyện toàn bộ những cái này mình sẽ mã
môn là một bạn sinh viên là một đã
13 này
ừ ừ
anh không không phải a luôn F4 thôi
số một này mã sinh viên vẫn là một mà
làm thế hệ 2 4 này chưa
a mã môn vẫn là một sinh viên là hai này
15 này
a tiếp theo ở
a mã môn là hai này bạn sinh viên là ba
này
số một này năm nữa Ok từ cái bàn như thế
này mình tạo ra nhân này có vẻ nhiều hơn
nhưng thực sự là mình cũng mỗi lần mình
thêm một điểm gì đó mình chỉ cần cập
nhật vào trong này đúng không Không thêm
sinh viên mà đúng không Thì là ổn đúng
chưa
Ừ đúng rồi ăn hết 40 tắt máy
ừ ừ
Ừ anh làm ở Đa ta nhiều mà không Tôi về
cơ bản trong hóa tôi rất là lười Tôi
lười động tay động chân nên tôi rất để
lười động tay động chân gì không phải
chăm động não để làm đầy đối
là đáng tội từng đăng câu châm ngôn là
như thế nếu không phải chăm phải mò được
cắt đúng không ạ
anh nói chung à Bây giờ mình cứ thêm một
môn thì mình nhập vào trong này đúng
không thêm điểm thì mình em vào trong
này bé xong không em
hẹn các bạn sẽ thấy là nó
Ừ nó kiểu Đây đây việc chia nhỏ ra nhiều
bạn bè nó dễ quản lí và tránh về lặp lại
dư thừa dữ liệu các thử thứ đúng chưa
thì ở đây Ừ cái này và câu
có một cái cau
thì chả câu sao nhưng mà để thử hỏi xem
ông nào đây biết trả lời luôn chứ nghe
nghe câu hỏi nhé
khi nghe câu hỏi nhé
ở
bảng này đầu tiên bà này đi
ở bảng lớp
từ khóa chính là Cột nào khóa chính ở
cột nào
anh ạ
nó bảo lớp Hoa Trinh Nữ buồn lắm nếu
không trả lời tôi đi
ở đâu rồi 110 ông nội
khi dễ quá Không Giờ Rồi
Em cứ trả lời đi yên tâm rồi sẽ từ từ
khóa dễ Tại sao có mã sinh viên bảng lớp
phải có mạng sinh viên là hỏng hộp có mã
đúng không màng quê quán thì khóa chính
là cổ nào
à à À thì ra tất cả đều quét mã nhà đúng
không Ok ba ngày thì
Ừ rồi bè hỏi lý mạng sinh viên vậy mà
sinh viên thì khóa phụ là Cột nào
ừ ừ
à Cậu đang trả lời câu nào đấy
các bạn sinh viên khóa phụ là quần áo
anh không Hôm nay mình không để đây rồi
cả hôm nay mình để nó là tốc độ cũng
bình thường này
khi mua ấy làm ông chết kìa Thế bây giờ
Thế là giờ rồi
ừ ừ tôi sẽ dừng để chèo có một ông và
trả lời đúng không
anh nghe kĩ câu hỏi nhá Đúng rồi còn trả
lời đúng rồi kìa không có khóa phụ khoa
ngoại Chứ bình tinh mày ông thế mà mail
cũng trả lời
ừ ừ
ý là khoa ngoại nhưng mà khóa phụ vợ nói
rồi đó là chỉ có khóa chính và khoáng
ngoại không có khóa phụ
xe đi chợ
à à
Hình như có đây Lỡ rồi có sao đâu đúng
không khóa ngoại thì mấy ông vừa trả lời
được đó là mạnh quê quán mà lớp đúng
không
ừ ừ
anh em mấy cái cô đơn giản thế mà ông
lại trời Sai rồi Đây đây đây Bây giờ mày
có khổ đấy bảng điểm thi thì khóa chính
ạ và cổ nào
ừ ừ
a
mã môn mã sinh viên
Ở lần thi
em chưa đúng
a mã môn mã sinh viên lần thi đúng rồi
bạn kia trả lời đúng rồi
ừ ừ
ở đây đây đây
ở bờ để tránh việc để các bạn mới Đoán
mò Nó ngon mình phải hiểu bản chất
Anh hiểu bạn chắc là tại sao lại thế đã
đúng không
Ừ ừ
các bạn
đầu tiên các bạn phải nhớ lại khóa chính
là gì đã khóa chính để làm gì đã ạ
từ khóa chính để làm đi thì các bạn sẽ
giải thích được và Cột nào trong trường
hợp này nó khóa chính
2012 chính Thế bây giờ rồi
thế chết bản nào cũng cần có khóa chính
không thể không không có khóa chính
trong mạng được đứng như là các bạn
không có khóa chính thì nó vẫn sẽ chạy
mà em từng nói rồi nhưng mà bà nào cũng
cần nên có phá chính
Ừ
đấy ông Kia là một trong điển hình hồi
trước mình cũng thường hay gặp và rất
nhiều ông từng làm đó tạo thêm một cột
nữa và đặt tên nó cục mã điểm thi vào
cuộc đời ra khỏi chính hàng hiệu để làm
gì đúng không
Ừ đúng rồi thứ nhất là quá trình ra đề
duy nhất và để liên kết bạn kia trời
thêm một ý giữa hai điểm B đến két được
hoạt khóa khóa ngoại của bảng khác nghĩa
trên mở khóa phụ dọn rác trên
đấy thì và đúng rồi để tránh trùng tại
đáy thì các bạn sẽ thấy đây đó là nếu mà
mã Bun Nếu giả sử mình mình cứ để bài
toán ra xử lý Thứ nhất nếu mã môn và
khóa chính thôi thì sao thì rõ ràng Các
bạn thấy không không được lặp lại ngô
này đúng không nó lại lỗi Đúng chưa ý
nghĩa là một môn chỉ phải Kim một lần
thôi đúng không cái tiếp theo Nếu mà mã
sinh viên là khóa chính mà không chỉ có
mỗi mã sinh viên và chín đi Ra đúng
không Thì sinh viên này không được là
bãi thế là sai rồi mà a tiếp đó là lần
Thiện Thế lần thi được phép ở lại mà
đúng không
Ừ thì rõ ràng là
ở ba cột này không thể từng cột là khóa
chính riêng được đúng không tiếp theo
hai cột này là hỏi chứ Như sao để hoa
thì các bạn thấy ở đây nghĩa là một sinh
viên một môn chỉ phép khi một lần thì
thì mới chạy được con nếu một sinh viên
cùng sinh viên này cùng Môn đấy mà lặp
lại phát nữa nó lại lỗi không đó đi do
mà ba ngày cùng phải là chính
Ừ thì ba cái này mới lặp lại nó mới lỗi
đã sửa bây giờ xử mình lại cho bạn Long
đấy Khi phát nữa đúng không
đèn này bạn ấy được lên hoàn 8 điểm y
ông thì nó lại lỗi bởi vì lần 1 nhập rồi
đúng không bạn một và bạn phải sửa vào
trong lần 12 là
à hay là bạn ấy cái tăng nó thành con số
mà đó để tránh bị lọc chưa đó nói do mà
cái khóa chính nó yếu tố do quan trọng
để quyết định ở đây đúng không Không
phải cơ cấu tạo nên một cục mã rồi để nó
tự động tăng cho vui được thì chưa
ừ ừ
em không có nhiều thầy cô dạy ở Thế ra
mình đôi khi mình không trách thầy cô
đâu bởi vì à
à mình mình hiểu được khi dậy thấy cô có
thể là thầy cô thấy khó quá ý mà mà là
dạy chuyên sâu ấy nhiều nhiều sinh viên
Khmer là một ra là mình biết nhiều thầy
cô nó nhận không hẳn là có chuyên môn
lắm theo kiểu kiến thức mà không sâu ấy
hoặc là có thể cô chính thức sâu cực thì
lại bị
khi con bị nhược điểm đó là ạ khi người
ta dậy lâu quá rồi
lễ hội thảo như thế vừa dậy lâu rồi nên
là họ Năm nào cũng dậy đi dậy lại đúng
cái câu đấy đôi khi ở sinh bị ăn bớt cái
câu mà đi kiểu kiểu thế
từ trước khi ở các bạn máy móc các bạn
theo kiểu đó năm nào thì nói đi nói lại
được đúng câu ý viên như thế còn không
thì được ra các bạn nói câu một câu mà 3
lần liền rồi thì sẽ
áo kiểu dáng sẽ ăn bớt Thành A là các
bạn bị
anh cứ tự còn hay bị những cứ tưởng là
mình nói cái đấy rồi thế này là mình
hiểu được mình người thông cảm thầy cô
như thế
Ừ nhưng mà Đấy tay buông tập lại cho các
bạn nào đã học rồi đúng không
Ừ đúng rồi cho ra nhiều Buổi trên lớp
của đại học chính quy thì nó nó lý
thuyết là Lâm mà nó ôm ôm hết toàn bộ
kiến thức các hướng hoặc là đôi khi ạ
Cái bài này là một trong những bài Buổi
đầu vì nó liên quan đến toán chẳng làm
thế
à mình mình dậy chọn hơn thì nó chỉ
tương đối nhanh thế ca buổi hôm nay nó
sẽ chỉ cần đến tương đối Thế là xong rồi
Nên là chắc là
các video đến tầm tiếng 40 phút thôi
thì các bạn còn thắc mắc gì không nhỉ Có
thể hôm nay nó sẽ lú hơi nhiều đấy đúng
không
khi lũ khách
ừ ừ
ở nhà Nếu không còn thắc mắc gì Chắc à
mình giao bài tập cho các bạn
anh tự tự ngồi thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu để
mà lại lũ tiếp đúng không
à À đúng rồi đúng rồi quên nhắc về
chuyên mục mình có hứa các bạn về cái vụ
viết cv nhỉ
anh không biết về còn thời gian
ừ ừ
sự
khác nhau bộ seri 2 đĩa
đã chúc mọi người chào mọi người chúc
ngủ ngon rồi chứ ạ
ừ ừ
ii-chương mình có học bổng không anh
Anh thật là ông hỏi đúng câu đấy đó là
hôm trước
À hôm trước Tự nhiên hôm ấy hướng lên
đầu tiên à một bạn hát rồi nhắn tin cho
mình hỏi mình CV của mình thì mình Lâu
lắm rồi mình mới viết cv của Vì thực sự
biết Savills cũng chẳng điểm gì khi mình
luôn qua được vòng phỏng vấn vì nó không
Không cần phải đi chứ gửi xe đi đâu đấy
nhưng mà thôi Mình cũng cứ ghi Vì năm
sau có cái Nhi lại ạ đúng không như mình
cơ làm mình đang lên như Facebook của
mình đã thử chứ Sau đó thì từ chính cái
CP ấy tự nhiên có một anh là trưởng vòng
mà tuyển dụng ở bên AFF Cup là FPT
Software
Ừ anh nhắn tin hỏi mình là muốn về dạy ở
đấy không ra mình cảm thấy là hồi trước
mình đi Mình học xong rồi trường của
mình được ở lại để mà dậy thì mình cảm
thấy kiểu mình bị ít cái kinh nghiệm
thực tiễn nên là mình cảm thấy da mình
phải bây giờ mình phải ra ngoài hóa trạm
ý nem đứa mình đang đi làm ở ngoài cho
mình không có đi dạy nữa
Ừ thì à mình thực sự bây giờ mình vẫn
chưa muốn quay lại đi dậy chắc là về Sao
không đi làm nổi nữa thì mình mới quay
lại giận nên là mình từ chối anh đấy về
việc là về đấy Dậy hay làm ở đấy mình có
công ty rồi Nhưng mà mình cũng hứa hẹn
với anh đấy là chắc là vì sao mình cũng
có thể về đây dậy vì nghe các thứ ấy ổn
phết thì
A
và mình có đề cập với anh đấy là nhóm
YouTube công ty đấy là mình mới mình mới
mở
ở bên mình mới nợ
digischool đúng không
Ừ thì bên bên đấy có muốn hợp tác để mà
tài trợ hay không thì bên này phải rất
hào hứng muốn tài trợ cho các bạn các
thứ khi đôi bên cùng có lợi mà nghĩa là
nếu mà các bạn mà học được đúng không
học để lập trình này mà ổn thì hoàn toàn
là
họ có thêm nguồn lao động các hư nên là
chắc Ảo
Em chuẩn bị sắp tới mình mình sẽ trao
đổi với anh Tuấn Nhưng cái vụ đấy ạ mình
đã chia sẻ trước các bạn thôi
ở đó là chuẩn bị sắp tới có thể sẽ có
thêm những cái gọi chương trình khuyến
học khuyến khích học tập cho các bạn
đúng không kiểu học bổng là ngồi nói
chung giải thưởng các thứ thứ mình nghĩa
nó một cái gì đó kiểu tạo động lực cho
bạn cũng như là
à à hỗ trợ cho nó bạn nào đang khó khăn
với Vân đúng không Thì thấy rất hấp dẫn
Ừ nhưng mà mình bảo ở thực ra cái này
sao chỉ mang mức tương đối rồi vì có
phải bạn nào học lập trình xong cũng
cũng theo được đâu đúng không Nhưng mà
mình tin là trong Ở đây toàn mấy ông
Điền hình trong chat này thấy nhôm trả
lớn làm bài tập game chắc rằng mấy ông
đang học công nghệ thông tin nhưng mà
cũng là nghe của tôi
nhưng thực ra thì
có thêm động lực mấy ông rất nhiều Tự
nhiên là có thêm
em có một nơi nó sẵn sàng nhận các từ
đúng không ạ
số xổ số ba miền sẽ mình nói trước Thế
với các bạn không hứa hẹn được điều gì
bởi vì mình là trao đổi với anh Tuấn Anh
sẽ định hướng Anh Tuấn nữa đôi khi có
nhiều cái nó hay lắm nhưng mình cho dù
anh Tuấn Long kiểu mới nhận nhận ra một
vài cái bởi vì anh ấy có thể định hướng
khác hay gì đó muốn động lực muốn
độc độc lập về các thứ chẳng không biết
được
Ừ Ừ
bên đấy sự ra có nhận đi tập và ngậm đào
tạo rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà kiểu bây giờ
họ ngày trợ riêng cho mình nghe có vẻ
hấp dẫn hơn mà không
khi họ nói điện một bên lớn nên là họ
sẵn sàng làm những cái đấy từ các nhóm
mình phải bé bị bỏng đúng không định lời
nói chưa ạ
10 Đại học Dự tính thực tế là bây giờ
vẫn đang dạy theo không có thuốc cái
giáo án chuẩn nào cả cũng chẳng có nơi
nào công nhận
ở đây à Cái này gần như đã học online mà
không hợp cho vui thôi bên nhiều trường
nó khi đang ghét tôi vì tôi cướp sinh
viên của họ
ừ ừ
à À vẫn lan man hơi nhiều nhỉ trưởng và
cách viết CV nhé trước khi
em hết rồi Ngon thì hôi trước là mình
thích cái này vãi mình phải nhắc ạ Mình
khoe Thằng Tí nó vincity.vn bạn nhưng mà
hình như công ty chết rồi
bị bán tất nhiên rồi ai sợ bị nói về bồ
qua lấy mình tạo toàn bạn CV này em bây
giờ mình đưa mình lại phải tạo suy nghĩ
ở trên topcv tranh thủ khoe tự nhiên lại
mãi giới thiệu được cho mấy người đấy
thì đây là Trang CV của mình nó để lộ
hơi nhiều thông tin nhạy cảm nó rồi ở
đây ta đi ạ
Ừ hi vọng ông ạ Không hoa đỡ được
nhưng đại xá như thế
à à Vừa rồi có ông thầy được
số điện thoại của tôi mất rồi đừng là
nhà anh nửa đêm nhé
thì tắt video
Ừ
nhưng mà
à à
Vì thế tôi đã phải lên Facebook rồi ạ
đang ở
em có gửi kết bạn này tôi không phải
chấp nhận đâu
Ừ không sao tôi cắt được
ở CV mình mình có đăng CP mình lên để mà
so sánh
- là livestream của tôi nên tôi được
phép khỏe mà mong cứ khoe anh em xem nhé
Đây mình thường hay đăng sinh viên mình
lên để mà
một ngày năm sau thì lại mình thấy mình
từng tệ nhà Hòa từng mong lành nha Vân
Vân à
Anh tên này nó ngon luôn là tên là tiêu
đề tiêu đề này cho cả hơi vớ vẩn thì hồi
trẻ trâu ấy
vì hồi lại cái tôi để tựa đề ngày vì ạ
vì cậu Cái mát của cái cái ngành của bên
trường tôi nói thế nhưng tôi để thế
ngồi đấy Không có gì ở khoe thì mình sẽ
anh
nói với những cái gì mình đang học đâu
mình đã có bằng cái gì đó mình thành
tích đạt được nó là gì thì tôi cố liệt
kê ở đây có thứ năm dài bị vàng dày
trường toàn dào lành Anh thứ
xôi kinh nghiệm qua lấy nổ vãi kiểu tầm
5 sao cứ bây giờ thì ra cạn lời
nói chung là cái CV này khiến nó tôi
kiếm được cái công việc thực tập đầu
tiên đây có địa chỉ nhà có số điện thoại
với sư phụ lấy lại sang bị đang là số
điện thoại địa chỉ đến đây nhá
Ừ thôi kệ đi nhờ địa chỉ là không còn
đúng đã nhà ông bền đốt nhà thôi đốt
nhằm nhà đấy đi
Ừ cái gì mày không bị thì mày cái gì đấy
Nói chung là đường vào nhà nghỉ dưỡng
thoại nhé
ở Mỹ thế nhưng rồi lại không Xóa Gửi ảnh
cái vậy
đâu nhá tiếp theo là
à à Hồi đấy tôi đang bởi vì Hồi đấy tôi
cuốn nổi không nhỉ Đúng rồi Mới đây tôi
không nổi nên tôi cứ đăng thôi nổi rồi
thì thì phải cho em mình cái thông tin
này đi
37 nói chung và hồi này là tôi hồi tối
biết viết cv rồi này cái này là từ hai
năm trước này đấy
anh không có ra không gái nào từ tế nên
em phải cắt xe như này đừng lý mặt nhá
Tớ xem mặt
thế giới thiệu xem mặt tối
á
Vừa nãy có hỏi tôi tôi đẹp trai không
Tôi khẳng định nhà tôi
ở công ty không tự tin về ngoại hình nó
lắm lại cho mặt ấy chưa bóng
đá Ý
à à
anh nói chung là các bạn cũng nên có mặt
à có ảnh có mặt nhưng nên nhìn được
ảnh cận mặt đáng có từ thứ
Anh tên này đúng không
Ẩm
Thực ra tiêu đề này một lần tiêu đề bằng
tiếng Anh như này họ tiếng Việt cũng
được mình khuyên bây giờ nên để tiếng
Việt rồi vì ạ Toàn bộ toàn
an toàn bộ cevia tiếng Việt tự nhiên
thoại tiếng Anh là mình hơi ghét thì
đánh nhau mạc tiêu đề này nên gắn Mác
của công việc mà mình sẽ Mình đang làm
và mình sẽ hướng đến
à à tiếp theo là Email Email thì các bạn
nên không nên để mấy cái Email thôi sẽ
sâu giống nhau giống như là
bật nắp quan tài tìm tìm em đã hoặc là
sau khi nhiều triệu trái tim tan vỡ các
thứ thứ không đáng để mình cái kiểu như
thế
bây giờ trẻ trâu
Nếu các bạn không có email nào chưa ta
thường Nhiều người tạo hàm của email cho
công việc như thế Nóng hạt tiêu đề không
đấy lớn như hồi nãy mình để là Nam Long
điêu lớp ơi A còn cái gì đó nó sẽ ổn hơn
số điện thoại nên để đúng không
em
không cho cái này của ông không giỏi
tiếng Anh thì ông không nên bằng tiếng
Anh Đương nhiên à Để cv tiếng Anh nhìn
trong 12 chuyên nghiệp hơn nhưng mà đừng
cố tỏ ra mình giỏi khi mà mình không đọc
nho
à tiếp theo link ở đây nhiều người còn
nói từng nhận xét lại về mình tại sao
anh dám để lên Facebook
a boy về cơ bản thì mai mà mình đã cố
biến cái Facebook của mình thành một cái
Trang nó vẫn là trang cá nhân hội nhưng
mà nó cái cha nó không làm cái gì đó
tiêu cực hay bậy bạ lên đấy cá không
văng tục gì chứ Này hay ra là hoàn toàn
có thể cho người ta xem qua được để biết
qua được con người mình là như nào hả
ông tạo Facebook mới của ông làm trong
nó hoành tráng em phân vân con không
được các bạn không nên khoe lên Facebook
mà nên là Linkin Tháp trưởng nó Linh về
cốt Các bạn đã từng cốt như nào như này
chẳng hạn nó còn hơn địa chỉ thực tế Các
bạn thấy nó khác địa chỉ với cái suy
nghĩ đầu tiên của mình không đó là không
nên để ghi mình cùng đi tên phố để mà
người ta hình dung được à các bạn đi từ
nhà đến công ty mất thời gian bao lâu
không đi mình nhi cụ thể địa chỉ mì cả
để nó vỡ đến Gõ Cửa nhà ông ạ chẳng cần
đúng không Bởi vì nếu mà thực sự nó cần
mấy cái thông tin liên quan đưa cả
ta thư giấy thì nó liên quan đến á
các giấy tờ khác rồi đấy
tiếp theo là ngày tháng năm sinh thì
đương nhiên là các bạn nên để tùy để dễ
xưng hô thôi đúng không Chị năng thì
không nên dùng cho CP đầu mình để vẫn 5
sao các bạn hạn chế Để năm sau gì đó Trừ
khi bạn tự tin cái đấy Hoa các bạn có
mỗi cái đấy thì tự tin
cái kiểu thế Anh không có bạn nên để nó
tầm 4 sao rưỡi hai giấy ở Trung Hoa chỉ
gần gần từ đối Cái gì đấy Thôi để anh
kiểm ngay sở thích
Em đừng có ông nào có sở thích kiểu gì
chẳng liên quan đến những ngành mà ông
Định đăng ký
anh có thể có một vài xử thích nó giống
trong thể thao Nó cứ thứ để mà ăn chị ạ
Thấy hiện ông con người hóa Đông được
vãi cả chơi được với tập thể Vân cảm
Được chưa không có giờ thích gì nó nó
vẫn nhấn mạnh ở không sợ đi thì trái
luồng liên quan đến việc các bạn không
đúng ảnh được nhiều cho sở thích xem
phim Hãy cấp thứ thứ họ nhạc Xem phim 18
+ à kiểu thế ở trong này nó chàng nghĩa
gì đấy đúng không ạ a tiếp theo Phần tóm
tắt tiểu sử về bản thân các thứ thứ Hạn
chế dùng đại từ nhân xưng là mình em tôi
không dùng được chưa là một con người
nào đó hai cái gì đó thì nó ổn lý hơn
hợp lý hơn
trụ sở chính số 13
các thứ tự kết hợp với cả thêm mong muốn
sau này ví dụ là mong một sau này như
nào lấy nó ra mục tiêu phấn đấu là cái
gì đó để người ta hình dung được các bạn
khi format quên em đi làm trên OneTV này
Nhưng mà tí Mình sẽ cho các bạn xem lại
cái túc CV mình topcv mình thì nó đơn
giản hơn rất nhiều khi mình sẽ mình sẽ
nói xong được gì đã tiếp và học tập học
tập thì tí các bạn sẽ thấy cái C gần
nhất mình mình chắn đấy cả pháp tập bởi
vì à mình có nhiều thứ đáng để khoe hơn
cái học tập của mình rồi thì mình sẽ
loại bỏ bớt đi thực tế là ngành cái
ngành của mình thôi là không quan trọng
bằng cấp lắm trừ khi các bạn đăng kí và
Nhà nước thì nên á các bạn không cần
phải đi cấp học tập Đấy chưa khiển các
bạn có chứng chỉ ngon hạn của bạn quen
nó ra được không sao
Ừ Cái quan trọng nhất là về kinh nghiệm
từ trước nhanh gần như là
một một người phỏng vấn người ta bị
nhiều nhất là về kinh nghiệm cũng như à
Mấy cái
thông thông tin tóm tắt sự tích các thứ
tư hơn là bằng cấp nhiều
Ừ
thì kinh nghiệm vào đây chị các bạn thì
lấy cây ra nào giống như cái kiểu dòng
Nó rất rồi à
a
ghi kiểu chỉ cần ngắn gọn như này mình
đã làm những gì mình đã áp dụng những
cái gì mình học hỏi thêm mình những kinh
nghiệm gì đấy Các thử thôi lo đi
ở đại tiếp tiếp theo dự án các đầu dòng
đúng không là được nhạc mình nghĩ thế
này ra ổn
anh cũng tương đối ổn rồi không
Em có suy vi
sự si mê này mình sivi này mình mình
trên mặt tôi không cần được chơi nữa đấy
thì
Ừ cái này là cái tiêu đề này tiêu đề mà
mình đã là cài mình đang hướng hướng đến
này hướng đến làm
em ở công ty này thì sẽ là như nào đấy
đúng không
cho số điện thoại ở đây tôi xóa đi rồi
nhưng mà thứ ra trên CV công khai đúng
không Email thì thơ địa chỉ ngay mà
chúng ta trong này ổn rồi này giới thiệu
bạn thân thì không chỉ cần mức ngắn gọn
ngay thêm cái mong muốn ước ước muốn nữa
cũng được tôi xóa sự với mong muốn tôi
đi vì tôi thực hiện được cái đây rồi
kinh nghiệm làm việc đấy các bạn thấy
sinh viên này của mình da ngắn hơn rất
nhiều nó không đề cập về vụ sở thích này
ở mình Thứ ba thấy không quan trọng nữa
trong ngày này cắn không quan tâm các
bạn thích làm gì à
hai kỹ năng này thì là từ cái kinh
nghiệm mạng xảy ra được kỹ năng thôi Nói
chung mình xin vi này của mình ạ một cái
Bạn vừa nhắn nếu mà các bạn dùng những
cái Nếu mình đã từng ôm cái này và những
cái template vừa rồi đấy nó nhắn một mẫu
thì ra là mình phải ôm một cái template
này
Ừ nhưng mà các bạn ạ chú khi các bạn
không muốn người ta nhìn thấy mặt mình
thì các bạn Bun trò chơi kiểu khẩu trang
nghe hay là chọn cái canh bếp mà không
có ảnh không không đi
thì các bạn điện ảnh chị tốt hơn mình đó
là hình dung nhìn qua bạn là con người
như nào đỡ bỡ ngỡ
cái liệt kê như này thôi đấy Đấy cách
viết sớ vi như thế ngắn gọn súc tích
bước dài dòng bữa cơm là đúng không
Mình không khoe ở Syria mình rất là ổn
Bởi vì thực sự thì mình hoa con nhà
người ta nói rồi Các bạn thấy rút ra nó
cũng chết mới đi làm bạn ơi mẹ con nhanh
người ta phải đi làm trước khi gọi tôi
đi học đại học rồi nhưng chưa hết
anh lại cách viết của sivi mình vì không
Mình chưa từng là nhà Tuyển dụng mình
thực sự là không biết được các nhà Tuyển
dụng thì sẽ sẽ cần thêm cái gì nhưng mà
Đấy là cách mà mình dậy ở sinh viên mình
cách viết CV đã à mình mình thường anh
dậy thị trường cách cho sinh viên mình
là thế
Ê mày lấy thì bạn mạnh vừa hỏi thì câu
rất hay này rồi kìa Thôi rồi đấy là mình
kinh nghiệm mình nó rất là yếu nên là
mình phải thêm những cái phụ trách Ngoài
Luồng của mình này khoe
mình khoe là mình đã từng làm một cái
phần mềm gì đó ở trên trường mình rồi
Hoặc là mình tự làm phần mềm chỉ đó theo
sở thích của mình Nó gọi là nó gọi là
best forex nữa mà trong nó ngôn ngữ lập
trình trong bệnh của bệnh tuy nó Black
Jack và những cái dự án nhỏ
từ nhỏ bé theo một cái sở thích của mình
thì các bạn nên khoe những cái này ngoài
những cái thứ mà các bạn được học chương
trường
Ừ thì sẽ rất tốt cho cho kiểu có thương
Khoe mà ngon Ê bà
khi người phỏng vấn với anh sẽ hỏi câu
là em làm cái này để làm gì đúng không
em đã áp dụng những cái gì để làm cái
này đúng không làm cái này xong Anh đúc
kết được những cái gì em nghĩ em cần
phải bổ sung cái gì cho cái này Vân Vân
để họ tư duy của các bạn khi dung bài
toán cũng như là các bạn có con người
cầu toàn vân vân vẫn có thử không
ở những nhà Tuyển dụng không thích ảnh
nhà
Ừ ông Tuyển dụng cái gì mà không thích
anh vậy à
ở Tuy nhiên là ảnh không nên kiểu nấu
quá thì chắc chắn làm Tuyển dụng không
thích còn thừa nhà Tuyển dụng sẽ luôn
thích ảnh đi
vì vậy mà người ta hình dung được qua
nhìn nhìn nhìn nhìn qua vẻ bề ngoài Các
bạn được đánh giá được phần mà không
à à
A gọi chính thức video này hơn hai tiếng
thôi nếu các bạn không còn thắc mắc gì
thì mình sẽ tổng hợp tất cả câu hỏi của
buổi hôm nay lại để buổi trao trả lời
nhá cho là mình tạm ngừng tại đây Thôi
nghỉ đi
em chưa à không cần ảnh hệ đâu trừ khi
các bạn vào những người môi trường gì đó
nghiêm túc và các bạn muốn
cho nhà Tuyển dụng nhìn các bạn làm con
người nghiêm túc với các bạn mới nên thế
thôi con vừa rồi ơi ảnh của mình nó
không hẳn là một cái ảnh chó nghiêm túc
lắm đúng không Các bạn thấy có tí gì đó
thể hiện con người mình trong đấy nên
thế nên ít ngắn ngọn giống như cái C gần
nhất của mình nhưng là thì dụng mẹ rất
thích nhìn nói Siri mới nhất của mình
luôn của việc nó thì hiện con người của
mình rất nhiều cái trong đấy Trà sự là
thấy mình đây đây nói à Giống như bà
trắng với tâm lý học
à à à Các bạn nhìn vào con người mặc
kiểu chị Chu đàng hoàng Thế thì một là
con người ấy con người giả tạo hai con
người đấy Còn mình nghiêm túc thật em
vân vân vân các thứ
các bạn lên topcv vừa rồi Mình có để
link các bạn có những cái form CV rồi
nhé Thôi vẫn hơi Lemon rồi có nhiều
không pha rồi Thôi mình tạm dừng lại đi
nhé em
ừ ừ